tadam bonjour à tous bonsoir à tous
bienvenue dans ce live a live test qui
est bien nous arrive
longtemps après la sortie d'un jeu culte
ce soir nous testons alors en
exclusivité mais c'est depuis et bien
bel et bien 50 minutes que vous pouvez
avoir les premiers tests qui sortent
mafia définitive les preview qishan et
privés ou pas et est les preview voilà
exactement donc un test mais qui ne
comprend pas la totalité du jeu
toutefois nous les testons et bien en
avant première puisque le jeu sort le 25
septembre
et comme je le disais hé bien c'est la
refonte totale d'un jeu culte mafia
définitive edition si bien vous êtes
intéressé par la trilogie mafia vous
n'étiez pas sans savoir que des versions
en remastered de mafia ii et mafia 3
était sorti alors ses versions elle
était sortie rester respectivement sur
ps3 xbox 360 et l'autre bien plutôt sur
ps4 et xbox one désormais sur cette
génération de consoles nous allons
pouvoir jouer et ça c'est un petit rêve
de nombreux joueurs je pense qu'ils
étaient fans de la première version de
mafia à mafia 1 avec et bien cette ville
de lost heaven est ce personnage
principal de tommy angelo si c'est le
fait vous disent pas grand chose et bien
sachez que vous allez pouvoir les
découvrir dans cette nouvelle version
qu'on va tester et dans quelques minutes
ensemble avec vous julien qu'une aile
vous êtes réalisateur pour figaro live
et vous allez voir une petite un petit
tour de magie puisque vous allez
réaliser ce live tout en jouant alors
que nous sommes en plateau alors là vous
pouvez pas le voir mais c'est une très
belle architecture qui nous a réalisé là
et moi je serai là pourrait bien prendre
tous vos commentaires poser quelques
questions puisque je suis un très grand
fan du tout premier opus qui était sorti
en 2002 donc il y a tout juste 18 ans
l'anniversaire même sera le 25 août donc
vous voyez qu'on est vraiment pas loin
avec la sortie se fait avec seulement un
mois de retard puisque le jeu sortira le
25 septembre
on est là pour t'aider c'est pour tester
tout cela je vous salue en tout cas d'où
piano sur youtube qui nous rejoignent et
n'hésitez pas à nous rejoindre
ce soit sur twitter ou youtube sur
lesquels nous diffusons cette preview
avec est bien là un menu principal qui
vous l'avez vu n'était pas tout à fait
bien ouvert puisqu'il manque terrible
quelques modes qui eux seront
disponibles lors de la sortie du jeu
notamment un mode libre
le mode quartier libre le mode quartier
arrive là tout à fait en fait un mode
open world tout simple c'est une version
sur laquelle on va on va reparler un
petit peu puisque c'est un petit peu
spécifiques et on a peu l'habitude de
voir ça c'est les drivers qui nous avait
habitués à ce mod d'open world désormais
bien on va pouvoir tester cela je vous
salue au passage et on a un grand
plaisir à vous retrouver comme très
souvent mis à waikiki lol on vous salue
n'hésitez pas à commenter à nous poser
vos questions si vous êtes est bien
intéressé par ce jeu et si vous avez
envie d'y jouer ou pas dites le nous ça
nous intéresse alors par quoi on va
commencer julien ben on va commencer par
découvert je crois ses premiers
chapitres or moi j'ai jamais joué à
mafia 1
c'est un voeu que j'ai toujours voulu
faire depuis très très longtemps et j'ai
même pu faire parce que battre
simplement le jeu est introuvable
vraiment en version quand je vois une
version qui marche sur windows c'est
très dur de le retrouver sur les jeux
les regards sont matérialisés je peux
vous le prêter mais c'est bien sur pc
ouais ouais mais faut ajouter des achats
a rejeté les patchs tout ça moi j'ai
essayé je devais acheter et caetera et
du coup annonça sa marche pas
ah dommage dommage avec donc eh bien
vous le voyez des graphismes bien 100%
refait je n'ai pas eu d'informations sur
la bo et ça on va attendre un petit peu
la sortie du jeu pour avoir plus elle a
été refaite complètement
elle a été refaite complètement à savoir
que dans les modes où pouvait se balader
dans notamment même dans certaines
missions
il y avait une bo très très très
qualitative avec du duke ellington du
django reinhardt qui reflétait vraiment
cette époque des années 30
bon bah on vous laisse découvrir cette
toute première cinématique quelques
minutes et on vous retrouve avant de
nous quitter pour ces quelques secondes
je vous salue cette béquille me demande
sur quelle plateforme sortira le jeu
alors pour le moment junior je crois que
c'est sur console uniquement alors qu'on
seulement il sort sur xbox xbox one
playstation 4 et pc a priori il devrait
sortir aussi assure stadia c'est très
compliqué de savoir s'il va sortir sur
stadia d'accord mais après j'ai envie de
dire maintenant je crois que tout le
monde s'en fiche il va sortir également
je crois peut-être sur switch et après
je pense qu'ils vont le ressortir sur
les prochaines consoles la playstation 5
et la prochaine xbox avec donc des
graphismes qui n'ont pas pas lire ça
c'est vraiment l'une des forces de ce
jeu vous le voyez la cdc ce sont
simplement des scènes mais in game que
le jeu est plutôt intéressant vous le
voyez en dessous il ya bien écrit
preview bild game not yet finale donc
c'est bel et bien une version non
définitive ce que vous verrez donc
reflète le jeu en grande partie mais pas
totalement c'est toujours important de
le rappeler
je n'ai pas pensé à vous saluer mais
bonjour chuck norris merci de nous
rejoindre sur youtube n'hésitez pas si
vous avez des questions on les prend
avec grand plaisir pour vous faire
découvrir ce jeu qui alors là julien ne
sera pas en version open world comme
hitler autres normal mais là on aura des
missions beaucoup plus scénarisé le mode
open war vue viendra avec la sortie du
jeu voilà nous on a une version en fait
des c qui nous a été envoyé par touquet
et donc du coup on a le début du jeu ici
je dis pas de bêtises je paye cash avec
moi je crois qu'on a un cinquième
chapitre bon moment c'est une fois qu'on
serait arrivé suffisamment longtemps on
va en fait il ya un saut dans le temps
qui fait jusqu'au cinquième chapitre du
ve à ce moment là en fait le but pour
tout cas il simplement pour les testeurs
de jeux vidéo de se rendre contre 2 à
quoi ressemble le jeu arrive au
cinquième chapitre avec toutes les armes
et tout les les possibilités débloquer
dans le jeu
alors moi je n'ai pas joué le jeu je
n'ai pas vu de test encore j'ai vraiment
là je deviens n'a pas n'y a pas de tests
en même temps que vous mais le premier
vous voir le test que vous avez fait en
preview mais je n'ai rien vu encore
là moi ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que certaines rues me rappelle certaines
choses allaient pas qu'il faut dire que
le jeu mafia il était assez bien
précurseur de beaucoup de choses il faut
dire qui à l'époque on était encore dans
l'est je ne sais même pas si gta iii et
est sorti je n'en suis pas sûr faudrait
le mini 2-6 6-1 2-6 laïcité
je crois que vaille et six titres et du
centenaire non ils sont retenus
je crois que tu en voilà c'est ça on est
donc quand même à une période où ce gta
iii a été sorti et alors là pour vous
expliquer un petit peu ce qu'on ce qu'on
peut voir et bien c'est tout simplement
un journaliste qui vient voir tommy
angelo le premier le personnage
principal pour jouer durant toute cette
histoire avec un très bon scénario il
faut dire que le scénario qui était ap
inspiré des affranchis à l'époque grande
partie à un film en deux je tue deux
films cultes comme le parrain par
exemple mais beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
des affranchis et donc bien finalement
là ce que l'on peut voir c'est un
personnage de tommy angelo qui va
raconter toute son histoire
un journaliste on vous spoiler part
c'est la toute première scène du jeu par
contre je vous dirai rien d'autre pour
que vous puissiez découvrir ce qui se
passe un petit peu dans ce scénario qui
est en tout cas s'il a gardé sa ses
racines vraiment riche vraiment à ses
fidèles à tout ce qu'on aime dans les
jeux de dans les jeux dans les jeux et
les films de des mafieux
que ce soit les affranchis que ce soit
le parent il y en a encore beaucoup
d'autres
et dernièrement des riches mène bien
évidemment avant que j'ai coché suivant
un précieux sinon j'aurais juste une
petite question est ce que ça te dit
quelque chose tout c'est ce que tu as
déjà vu du coup toutes ces cinématiques
dans le
l'édition de 2002 oui ça c'est une
cinématique qui était identique et même
la petite séquence de balade dans la
ville
ouais elle n'était pas tout à fait
identiques mais c'était vraiment ça et
c'est ça qui est intéressant alors pour
moment ça me fait plaisir c'est qu'on a
gardé le même scénar est ce que je vois
aussi c'est ce que j'ai pu voir en tout
cas dans l'est dans les temps les bandes
annonces
on a pu observer bien c'est que les
grands personnages sont là et donc une
histoire sera respectée maintenant il
faut voir si cette version sera bel et
bien
fidèle à ses origines alors unsa que ce
sera réponse le 25 septembre pour sa
sortie mais en tout cas pour le moment
cela respecte particulièrement
merci pour vos précisions 7b qui nous
dit que le jeu gta iii est sorti en mai
99 s'il vous trompez pas bon on vous
fait confiance et voilà en tout cas
c'est il faut dire que avant j'étais à
trois dents n'étaient plus tôt sur
driver driver 1 et 2 voilà on était
sortis et qui va nous écouter un petit
peu à l'open world un peu comme mafia
puisque et bien il y avait des missions
d'un côté et un mode open world à part
entière sans mission sans rien avec
juste en fait la possibilité avec un
certain nombre d'armes de se balader
dans la rue avec une sélection de
voitures au tout début on était vraiment
dans un mode presque émission de l'open
world et qui était nommé tout à fait
atteint mais qui se respecte est tout à
fait choper un [ __ ] de torticolis
on vous laisse profiter un petit peu du
scénario allez on vous laisse écouter un
petit peu la qualité normalement vocal
puisque la des nouveaux acteurs ont été
ont été recrutés pour faire pour faire
les voix du passé porte sans moi on
s'est tous les deux tu fais pas de
mettre sans prendre une balle
mais si tu restes ici tu raconte ta
jolie petite histoire va savoir
peut-être que tu vivras assez vieux pour
voir ta fille se marier dans tous les
cas je suis bon pour payer un café
bertin jamais pu vraiment tout ça
a mal tourné
personne ne voit jamais rien venir avant
que ce soit trop tard j'imagine que tu
es pas né dans le milieu je me trompe
j'étais taxi ça remonte aux années 30
[Musique]
je pensais surtout de nuit ça rapportait
plus
ce jour là je venais de terminer des
survols alors là avec si vous aimez la
culture liée à la mafia dans notre
culture le cinéma les jeux vidéo les
livres aussi puisque l'euro le parrain
par exemple les tissus d'un livre à la
base et bien là on a eu une référence
avant même que l'on puisse voir cette
course poursuite une référence directe
aux parrains une offre qui ne se refuse
pas c'est 9h15 chose qu'on a pu voir la
première fois dans le parrain avec et
bien ces scènes ses scènes cultes
notamment de la tête de cheval alors on
vous laisse donc découvrir cette scène
où atomique il a est le personnage
principal est tout simplement un
chauffeur de taxi et se retrouve nez à
nez avec des bandits qui deviendront ses
meilleurs amis pour un certain temps
j'ai envie de dire sans rien régler mais
comme dans tous les films de mafia
vous savez que c'est un peu difficile
dans ces milieux en fait sa démarche
tout de suite en fait le gameplay ça
fait comme à l'époque du temps mais
c'est vachement hausse avec les
graphismes ont quand même été bien bien
ça presque version de 2002 pour avoir
regardé des gameplay les traders etc
c'est moi il faut trouver par exemple
elle faisait des choses que
les jets de diane elle était beaucoup
plus réaliste ce remake un gta parce que
par exemple quand cette mission du taxi
était assez spécifique et là on l'a
toujours évidemment à cette époque mais
à l'époque c'était beaucoup plus rares
les impacts de balle là vous voyez que
vous en avez déjà 12 9
mais les impacts de balles rester et
surtout la le pilotage des véhicules et
j'ai beaucoup plus complexe alors je
sais pas s'ils ont gardé sa julien arias
et vias et si vous voyez gta iv qui
était beaucoup plus simulation
effectivement ça beaucoup plus penser au
gameplay de voitures de gta iv qui était
beaucoup plus difficile que san andreas
ou que gta 5 quoi et ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui était propre à mafia
qui sont gardés dans le 2 vous avez fait
trois jeux mafia 3 alors du coup j'ai
pas fais mafia 3 alors je refais mafia 2
justement pour la ressortir de mafia 1
en édition masters en fin ou remake
comme vous voulez et j'ai toujours pris
beaucoup de plaisir à faire marcher
dehors je suis refait du coup dans la
nouvelle édition qui est ressorti donc
la définitive édition est en fête
malheureusement rien n'a été corrigé de
tous les problèmes de mafia ii à
l'époque
d'accord c'est à dire que du coup j'ai
eu un bug de sauvegarde etc
enfin bref l'un d'eux qui consacre les
gens là on est vraiment sur une refonte
complètement refait jeu et je crois que
c'était vraiment le l'intérêt même en
fait d'heureux sortie de mafia trilogie
certain de pouvoir composer ce mafia un
bon recrutement on refait quoi alors
déjà ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
la tendance en tout cas du sénat a l'air
beaucoup plus dans le spectaculaire
puisque dans la version d'origine cette
mission que je connais rigueur on avoir
fait plusieurs fois j'ai fini je pense
trois mois et vient est risqué voilà
tout simplement une course-poursuite y
avait pas de voitures qui se mettre
devant n'y avait pas de choc parce que
s'ils ont choqué des voitures enfin si
j'ai choqué si on percute et des
véhicules
on se bat en fait on était vraiment
ralenti et les voitures étaient très
fragiles à l'époque qui avait pas ce
genre de choses que vous pouvez voir des
petits interruption avec des voitures
qui sont au passage bon jour là qu'ils
007 merci de nous rejoindre n'hésitez
pas si vous avez des questions des
réactions à nous donner
on les prend avec grand plaisir alors
que là et bien alors vous ne connaissez
pas encore mais je viens le personnage
de pauli qui sera un petit peu votre
acolyte principal
reprendre un petit peu un personnage
très connu des affranchis un superbe jeu
vers interprétée comme telle star prix
du pain genre littéralement poli
polyglotte au mal oui c'est vrai c'est
vrai que c'est un peu prénom clichés
italien l'amérique si oui ou non ce
n'est pas un sport parce que vous allez
le voir il vous allez le voir
c'est par ce prix vous inquiétez pas
donc voila vous le voyez en tout cas une
conduite un peu plus nerveuse dans ce
jeu on peut pas aller à fond jusqu'au
bout d'une route et se dire qu'on va
faire un dérapage là pour commencer un
taxi ça va pas très vite on est dans les
années 30
c'est pas fini alors rendez vous y est
en tout cas est beaucoup plus difficile
c'est notamment dans le mode
on va se balader et bien c'est que je ne
sais pas si c'est conserver vous pourrez
peut-être venir peut-être que vous
l'avez eue mais je suis pas sur mais
dans les modes open world est rien il ya
une vitesse d'une limitation de vitesse
que si on dépasse et que si on se fait
avoir par la police et bien il nous
poursuivent et donc alors c'est pas
grave il ne tire pas dessus comme dans
un jt alors que ce qu'on a une étoile ou
deux admettent une prune il te met une
prune donc théorie j'ai hâte arrêté est
obligé de me la prune alors c'est rigolo
c'est sympa c'est comme dans mafia 2
mais voilà exactement et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que en fait c'est pas
grave en soi qu'on en open world mais
quand on est en mission
eh ben il faut apprendre à gérer son
temps et ça c'est vraiment autre chose
ça c'est de l'action sas et de buster
américain ça se voit là y'avait il y
avait passé dose d'action si on était
beaucoup plus terre à terre en 2002
c'est ça que moi j'apprécie en tout cas
c'est que c'était on s'y croyait
vraiment mais bon là c'est pas non plus
on n'est pas non plus dans un michael
bay j'ai envie de dire bonjour votre
aimable serviteur sur youtube merci
d'être avec nous voulons demander sur
quelle plateforme sort le jeu est bien
le jeu sort tout simplement sur ps4 xbox
live et pc on n'a pas d'info je crois
julien sur la sortie potentielle sur ps1
que je pense pas que leur adversaire a
priori winter a priori oui devrait
sortir sur ps1 qui donc pas exclue sql
serait une version adaptée à la paix est
5e juste tout simplement cette version
retranscrite en doute fort façon tous
les jeux qui sortent actuellement sur
playstation 4 et qui vont en sortir sur
playstation 5 comme au hasard skyrim ne
sera parfait non non non et pareil pour
gta 5 qui annonce et qui d'ores et déjà
annoncé je crois sur playstation 5
il n'y aura pas de rien ne sera refermée
c'est juste un portage simplement et ça
je pense que ce sera la même chose pour
ce match mais c'est déjà amplement
suffisant là on joue d'ailleurs si vous
voulez avoir un bon aperçu après ça
dépend de connexion vous arrivez à voir
avec youtube mais utx mais du coup on
joue en fait avec les graphismes au
maximum ce truc que j'ai dis que j'ai dû
désactiver qui faisait vraiment ramé pc
c'était à synchro verticale
c'est le seul truc mais sinon on est un
ultra surtout en fait là d'accord donc
là on joue vraiment foule
fuld graphismes en sachant que dans ce
jeu les cinématiques sont comme dans un
gta avec des graphismes in game donc ya
pas de ya pas de mode aléatoire ou ou de
mode avec des cinématiques qui sont un
peu plus embellie non non pas du tout
bonjour à vous et merci de nous
rejoindre nos limites
ron n'hésitez pas si vous avez des
questions des réactions à ce jeu là on
voulait prend avec cette scène qui était
très bien mise en avant avec tommy qui
commence un peu à flipper puisqu'il voit
quelqu'un qui sort et qui de façon assez
prépondérante un mafieux et quittant
quelque chose en dehors de sa veste et
en fait c'est une enveloppe et ça va lui
faire comprendre que peut-être qu'il
faudrait changer le monde et partir du
monde des taxi pour aller dans un monde
un peu moins
comment dire un peu moins légal c'est
une référence à taxi driver de scorsese
mais pas partout voilà il ya la lasser
mais c'est vraiment laid c'est ça qui
est intéressant c'est qu'on a très très
peu de références au parent alors
l'appareil parent qui est mon film
préféré donc mon jeu préféré mon film
préféré je pense que je peux vous le
dire
jusqu'il ya du jeu vidéo le parrain
officiel sorti sur playstation 2 sur wii
était pas mal à moi j'ai adoré mais il a
une lan trésor à 14 sur le nom était
maladroit mais mais mais j'ai bien aimé
le côté moi c'était le truc que j'avais
fidèle au film passe qui est un prof
c'est qu'on pouvait contrôler business
ouais c'est tout cas ça c'était dans le
deux pas dans un nom dont l'a d'ailleurs
prouvé contre eux et les business à un
certain âge vous paris mam on braque
d'accord mais pas rentrer dans le
deuxième set à miami
et en plus dans le 2 juillet les
quartiers les business ça c'est vrai
bien non c'était tout simplement une
refonte du film on
vous pouvez refaire les scènes du film
et ça déjà quand on est un petit fan
sauce du bas rhin on est très très très
content quand c est donc dans les jeux
de mafieux qui ont été retranscrits dans
les films de mafieux qui ont été
retranscrits à l'écran géant
vidéoludique on à scarface avec une
magnifique entre guillemets bo de rohff
jeunes anciens très bien ça lorsqu'un
fait ce qui n'était pas non plus un très
bon jeu j'ai pas fait on a eu le palais
2 qu'est ce qu'on en a eu d'autres
est-ce que vous avez des souvenirs alors
je sais qu'il y avait un jeu qui
s'appelait gangster qu'il y en a eu une
suite aussi sur pc je n'y étais plutôt
large de gestion en vue du dessus à tout
à fait série sorti en 99 fois ouais ça
c'était bien aussi je vais pas fuir et
là c'était vraiment un jeu de gestion de
business et de et de quartier en fait
tout simplement
sinon qu'est-ce qu'on a eu on a
peut-être eu des jeux voilà non je n'ai
pas beaucoup de souvenirs là celui-ci
dans le chat vous en avez n'hésitez pas
à nous les donner ce sera
particulièrement intéressant et ne
pourra échanger
mais voilà alors après je vous disais
que c'était pas si proche du parrain
bien évidemment il ya plein
d'inspiration dont sarah notamment dans
ce genre de scènes qu'on peut voir à
l'ancienne ou vraiment dans les années
30 où là on peut revoir quand même dans
notre petit coeur de fans de cinéma
certaine ambiance et certains univers
puisque on vous le rappelle les
affranchis ne se passe pas à cette
époque ça se passe pas dans les années
30 mais ce qui est intéressant c'est de
voir que ma que voilà il se fait ça
comme ça et donc là c'est une référence
au film taxi avec samy nacery exactement
égale bien joué et bien joué
là vous allez appuyer sur un bouton
et un spoiler des enjoliveurs spéciaux
de sortir et oui évidemment mais c'est
vrai que l'air taxi qui est aussi des
adaptations en jeux vidéo qui était ma
foi bien sûr j'avais deux sur ps1 ouais
ça sent très bon souvenir mais ce
n'était pas un très bon jeu c'est tout
simplement un jeu de top chrono
il fallait respecter locarno dans la
ville et mais moi j'ai fait taxi 3 sur
playstation 2 aie aie aie pas dans les
meilleures heures du jeu vidéo
non mais c'est parce que ses forces et
tout essayé un seuil en fait du taxi
najoua taxi de l'acteur jeu français
enlevés bissau qui était taxis aussi
c'était sûr dring ah oui mais c'est
autre chose
voilà si vous voulez jauge des
références moi je vous prends je
visitais active rsa créé des taxieurs
moi je l'adoré crazy taxi mais moi je
peux je jouais sur la borne d'arcade que
j'avais
les mains à côté de chez moi et c'était
assez fou gérer mais bien le levier de
vitesse arnhem c'était une voiture
automatique évidemment pour la bande
d'arcade mais ça restait quand même
assez apprécié avait été assez ouf
alors vous voyez en bas à droite de
votre écran on vous disait qu'on peut
gérer la vitesse alors là il faut dire
que julien ne respecte pas trop la
vitesse limite aux meilleurs et oui ça y
va les conduire prudemment respectant la
loi
oui tout à fait mais mais j'ai pas
trouvé bouton surtout si vous le voyez
en bas de votre compteur de vitesse il y
a également un compteur de fioul puisque
dans ce jeu vous devez aussi gérer votre
essence et c'est ce que je trouve assez
incroyable alors pour beaucoup leur
stabilité a si peu je sais pas un petit
peu ennuyeux parce que c'est vrai que
quand on joue aux jeux vidéo je peux pas
trop à se prendre la tête sur la vitesse
et sur notre essence mais moi je
trouvais que cette dose de réalisme elle
apporter quelque chose d' authentiques
vraiment impressionnant au jeu et donc
eh bien quand on se moque hull en panne
d'essence par exemple on a trouvé une
belle voiture qu'on a envie de la garder
elle va falloir faire attention et
surtout si on est bien suivie par la
police et ça ça arrive très souvent
quand on a bien essayé de jouer à l'open
noir mais forcément obligé de sortir un
petit peu des sentiers battus entre
guillemets eh bien il va falloir aussi
gérer son essence est allé faire le
plein de temps en temps et ça ça fait
partie du réalisme du jeu alors là pour
le moment j'ai pas l'impression que
vitesse 12 ha non mis dans le rouge
vis-à-vis de la loi
alors non mais non mais surtout on va
pas fichés bouton sur lequel s'est
appuyé pour pour mettre limiteur de
vitesse dans ces mieux fait dans mafia
de limiteurs de vitesse dans mafia 2
c'est mieux faire on dit tout de suite
oui mais ça se passe l'entente après
vingt ans après il y avait encore
limiteur de vitesse juste indiqué c'est
une bonne question si vous êtes fan de
mécanique dites le nous on sera une
histoire là je pense que ça parle plutôt
d'histoire fait d'aveux et limiteur de
vitesse
ouais fouiller les rues de ce faux pas
tellement fouillé ouest et jean à
wimereux indique très clairement oui
vouliez vous y avait un peu joué déjà ou
pas non pas du tout pas du tout je veux
garder la surprise pour d'accord bien
c'est toujours intéressant en reste on
découvre le jeu à fond
time attack voilà bon vous propose des
missions alors ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure c'est que c'est un jeu
open world là comme je vous le disais
déjà une version à une open world qui se
trouve en fait être la version
l'histoire vous avez donc deux modes un
mode open world un mode histoire et ce
match histoire
eh bien vous permettra de vous balader
au sein des missions dans la ville
certes je sommet russie otan brut soit
entre deux missions ne s'est pas comme
un gta où vous allez essayer de
dispositions de rejoindre à peu près
respectées l'école de rejoindre de
rejoindre tel ou tel endroit choisir
telle ou telle mission
la cie en tout cas le mode l'ancien mode
de respecter et je pense qu'il baissera
et vient de mado peur ne sera pas
disponible au sein du mode histoire si
vous voulez faire de l'open world il
faut aller dans un mode à part et là
vous avez pas de mission et vous balader
dans la ville et profiter un petit peu
de ce que le jeu à vous à vous offrir
c'est étonnant qu'un choix de la part de
tout coeur qui est donc un le studio qui
à l'origine du jeu même déjà en 2002
c'était tout cas el cheikh qui avait qui
avait fait le jeu tout cas tchèque qui a
un très bon studio puisqu'ils ont fait
mafia et et surtout top spin ah oui
d'accord et oui c'est aussi les
créateurs de t'exprimer ah oui c'est
vrai et c'est ce qu'ils ont fait le
meilleur jeu de tennis soit pour moi le
dernier grand jeu de tennis et autres
spin 4 sur 360 et pc sa playstation 3 et
wii mais version wii entendu là aussi si
vous avez des réactions des réactions je
t'ai 15 secondes et bonjour si vous avez
dit que tous les salons si vous
souhaitez qu'on fasse certaines choses
dans le jeu n'hésitez pas à nous le
demande et on sera là aussi pour le
faire alors sachant que peut pas tout
faire non plus hein c'est une version
limitée
non mais par exemple rouler sur les
trottoirs ou faire des choses comme ça
oui alors c'est vrai que le jeu est
particulièrement définit la snm
carrément vous vous arrêtez c'est
c'est un poil plus linéaire que le jeu
mais c'était une mission qui était déjà
présente où vous faisiez le taxi que je
me souviens qui discute avec les gens ce
qui jouera c'est sympa prochain wei
apparemment la phase narration alors
assez développée dans ce bois d'amont un
peu comme dans comment me fais documents
qu'elle a été doublée en français lavaux
gens en france aient un jour en france
est vrai et là le jeu est doublée en
français ce qui n'est pas dans le cas
dans les gta par exemple et qui pour
certains joueurs et peut être réviser
l'histoire je passe bien sûr par dont
j'allais quand je mets le truc je picole
d'accord il est bourré mais par contre
on peut mettre en anglais alors j'ai pas
réussi
j'ai essayé de le mettre en vo st mais
j'ai pas réussi pouvoir tu trouves code
de la route mais façon il est bourré il
se rendra pas compte mais donc du coup
j'avais essayé de le mettre en anglais
et ça n'a pas marché
a priori en plus sur la version démo qui
nous ont envoyé bas n'a pas réussi d'une
tant pis on y vivront foule vfg pas si à
l'époque on avait déjà le choix de la bo
de lever
non alors moi je l'avais en vf et je ne
peux pas vous dire là c'est une très
bonne question mais je pense qu'il lui
est récupérée en vo ça ne m'étonnerait
pas en 2002 c'était assez rare c'est
vrai dans le début le début des années
2000 monstrueux à chaque fois tung et
tourne sur les forums
chacun d'eux des moyens pas de français
mais c'était toujours en général ceux
qui avaient ce qui demanderait pas de
français s'étaient ce qui n'était pas du
jeu alors sur la petite carte note en or
maman vous avez certaines indications
moi je serais curieux de voir si vous
pouvez faire un petit plein la gauche
juste à gauche vous avez une
station-service nous montrer comment ça
se passe where d'accord mais moi je veux
bien mais j'étais censé reconduire le
poivrot ouais mais là vous n'avez pas de
véhicule alors du coup faut quoi faut y
répondre
on a fait un petit pas pour donner pour
gars non mais mais non mais y est fermé
il est fermé
bah c'est pour ça non non si si et fermé
6 6 mais en fait je me souviens très
bien qu'il y avait en fait un un
pompiste qui était dehors et qui vous le
faisait dans fallait s'arrêter à côté du
pompiste donc là c'est que ça lui
pendant le scénario peut être qu'il y
ait pas j'espère sincèrement qu'ils ont
gardé ce mode dans le mode open world
puisque vraiment c'était un plus
bref s'il vous plaît et donc on a vu à
la conduite qui est un peu plus
difficile d'accès il y avait écrit faire
le plein au diben reaper face à bah il
faut pour vous y retournez à travers une
menace mais pas de pompiste mais il y
avait les banques étaient fermées mais
non il ya des planches en bois
alala 1 est fermé il est parti en
vacances au mois d'août il pas encore en
vie humaine risque fort de cette scène
là avec le café les ondes pas et
cliniciens quand vous payez pas vos
factures d'électricité dégâts donc là en
fait
ça ce sont des hommes de morello qui est
la famille rivale des salles guéri et
les séries qui vont être la famille avec
laquelle on va on va jouer donne salieri
qui est le grand à oui je me souviens
très bien de cette mission c'était super
elle était très bien scénarisé elle
était là où il faut courir par contre là
ouais c'est vrai que c'est pas évident
de faire à une réalisation plutôt
renvoie donc la spéciale dédicace à pire
pilet de le figaro live qui n'a pas
réussi à passer cette mission mais vous
en sortez très bien géré a et donc non
une vie une version qui était très bas
qui était assez identique à cette
version là c'est ça qui me fait plaisir
et voilà qu'ils étaient assez scénarisé
mais qui marchait bien franchement
c'était assez joli à voir
à l'époque la si vous y jouez maintenant
vous allez voir que c'était c'est un peu
datés mais ouais on était là dessus avec
les les tirs de balles autour de nous et
ça pareil les tirs de balles étaient
identifiés dans le mur ah oui parle et
ça c'était assez nouveau par exemple
dans un gta bas les balles ne restez pas
ça faisait juste un soir il fait et
voilà on ne voyait pas les bonnes c'est
un peu une scène dont il était une fois
en amérique à sergio leone
on est un peu moins dans le monde des
gangsters mais on est un peu dans la
même période alors que ceux des mafias
aussi oui mais qui pour moi cet univers
interne qu'avec 1 à 15 heures des
affranchis vous voyez ce que je veux
dire oui c'est plus c'est plus
mélancolique et dramatique tu as fait
c'est plus long aussi
bonjour tyco ercis merci d'être avec
nous n'hésitez pas à réagir on prend
tout commentaire tout vos réactions
bonjour sextoys ce que j'ai plaisir à
voir à retrouver sur twitch nous dit
c'était donc mafia et pas pigé à 2021
oui j'ai pu voir votre retour sur
twitter
vous avez donc perdu contre le real et
donc vous ne recevrez pas votre copie de
pga 2021 si je m'en tiens si je m'en
sors les indices sur twitter on n'avait
pas et se sont tous qu'on aurait pu vous
donner c'est un code figaro premium et
on en aurait plus toutes les parties
comme des petits pains désolé grand
grand grand pardon mais merci d'être
avec nous ce soir ça fait plaisir
et moi je dois vous dire que je suis
plutôt content de voir que ce soit mafia
ce soir parce que j'étais très très très
curieux de voir de quoi avait l'air le
jeu donc là vous voyez vraiment la
première approche de tommy angelo qui
personnage principal et qui rentre pour
la première fois dans un bar dans lequel
on va être très très très souvent c'est
un petit peu l'épicentre du jeu donc il
ya ce bar là vous rencontrer l'ensemble
de l'équipe avec bien les différents
statuts qu'on peut voir dans les films
de gangsters avec les caps au régime qui
vont être un peu plus haut dans le dans
la hiérarchie avec les consignes
guerrila vous avez un consigli qui aura
fort à faire dans ce dans cette version
du jeu et donc vous le voyez c'est senna
l'acétone sa lyrique et le grand chef on
vous laisse écouter ses premières lignes
qui sont importantes dans le scénario
t'appelles comment thomas
thomas angelo monsieur
on peut dire que tu as eu des soucis
mais monsieur mon taxi a salement morflé
légal morello s'en sont pris à lui parce
que tommy nous a aidés ce taxi c'est on
gagne pain même si je me sens un peu
responsable tu sais
donc je te propose un petit prêt juste
de quoi retaper ton tacots écoutez je
vous suis très reconnaissant mais je
suis pas là pour l'argent
alors de quoi on parle je veux juste
pouvoir me faire les [ __ ] qui ont
défoncé mon taxi tendance à franck le
môme veux ma permission pour aller se
castagner oui j'ai entendu
[Musique]
ok tommy angelo
tous les gorilles de mort alors que je
vois que ben reaper est un fan du jeu on
a dit que puel pauli est un soldat lors
le soldat si vous donnez cette fois
c'est vers le statut le plus bas dans
pour ces cas les niveaux des mafiosos
vous le vix à metallica est vraiment à
la question avoue bonnery perth et qui
est franc qu'il allait manquer quel
statut
je voudrais savoir si vous avez suivi et
si vous avez de bons souvenirs mois il
m'avait marqué ce personnage de frank
qui était très attachant et au mercy ex
tu ne dis pas d'un côté ça me rassure ce
soir mafia bien meilleur jeu à mon goût
je suis d'accord avec vous mais je suis
pro mafia à 100%
et voilà bien jouer man reaper franck
c'est le concile irie de dun s'allient
pour vous donner un peu plus d'infos là
dessus le concile guérissent et tout ça
tout simplement
l'avocat de la famille qui est là pour
pour s'occuper un petit peu d affaires
c'est le rôle de tommy gunn dans le
parrain qui est joué il s'appelle cet
acteur qui joue dans ce cas la ligue se
navre james khan nord sas et non lui ses
sept fils du parrain c'est sony quand il
s'appelle cet acteur qui jouait dans
apocalypse now et qui aime l'odeur du
napalm au petit matin
non mais j'étais sûr c'était non on en
annonce et james kane c'est c'est sony
qui se fait descendre à reims comme ils
s'appellent je vais vous retrouver tout
de suite son nom j'oublie à chaque fois
je leur ai pas de
j'aurais pas dû lui non plus à d'autres
que c'est très dur pour ça s'est traduit
en français que ses gentils nous qui ne
comprenons pas la langue de molière
donc ça y est je vous écris robert
duvall merci beaucoup
google robert duvall donc ta mais oui le
rôle de tommy gunn voilà bravo ben ben
reaper
vous nous dites voilà oui robert duvall
s'extasie essa bien joué merci pour ce
très grand acteur que j'adore et mais
j'oublie tout temps sombres puisque pour
moi je retiens juste sur nous vous le
voyez dans le film le parrain plutôt que
son nom d'acteur
voilà donc vous voyez cette scène au
sein du barde et salieri un bar
important puisque c'est le qg de la
famille et c'est ici que tout se passe
vous aurez notamment le garage vous
allez pouvoir amener des véhicules et
les sauvegardes et vous allez pouvoir
enfin en tout cas si c'est comme à
l'ancienne vous allez pouvoir aussi
choisir vos armes si je me souviens bien
c'est fait vraiment très longtemps
depuis mais voilà on a on va y passer
beaucoup de temps on va avoir pas mal
d'aventurés là dedans
et surtout c'est très immersif et on s'y
croirait vraiment s'ils croyaient déjà
les poteaux et voilà et ça c'est la cour
dans laquelle vous allez pouvoir vous
balader contre les grands demande
d'aller au garage si je ne m'abuse et on
va vous donner notre première arme remis
remercie en tout cas ça fait plaisir
d'avoir autant de fidèles un flic bon
jour sur youtube qui nous dit robert
duvall également jour brume sur youtube
dangereux merci et vincenzo qui est un
petit peu lahrari vous allez voir il est
carrément aux normes huriez je te
présente tommy angelo lui et moi on est
sur un court d'accord il vous faut des
mitraillettes de flag
non il nous faut juste de quoi caresser
des trois caisses aux jets pile ce qu'il
vaut
ça me fait penser à public enemies avec
johnny depp par michael mann public
enemies qui sorti en 2000 sur la vie du
la vie du grand john dillinger est bien
sûr question tu vois je m'appelle
non-violence et je trouvais c'est un
super film il était très simple avec
marion cotillard avec moi que dia et
avec christian bale qui était du coup à
la pire erreur de casting que j'ai pu
vendre un film depuis un bon moment
puisque malheureusement mais johnny depp
on est plutôt baird a été incroyable je
trouve sur jonnhy depp cuir très bon
occasion que vous l'avez vu et je vais
rebondir sur votre commentaire sex-toys
qu'est ce qui nous dit en fait ils ont
juste mis un coup de polish sur le jeu
non c'est un peu méchant non non non
mais c'est pour moi c'est bien c'est
parce que en clair au contraire on garde
on regarde la base du jeu alors
j'attends de vous voir jouer un peu de
la battait du pistolet pour vous dire
s'il y en a tant que ça on attend tous
que ça c'est sain c'est un simple coup
de polish ou si au contraire il ya eu
des améliorations puisque le jeu avait
des défauts vous n'êtes pas sans le
savoir
et c'est ça qu'il faudrait qu'il
faudrait voir mais en tout cas on va
pour le moins à wii avec donc ce
personnage râle fille qui est qui est
souvent très gêné mais qui va vous étiez
le meilleur garagiste on va vous dire le
meilleur gardien
vous voyez en tout cas c'est très très
très fidèle à la version d'origine comme
ça ça fait plutôt plaisir
effectivement en fait c'est un bouton
pour pouvoir passer sur le moteur de
l'époque de 2002 et sur un autre bouton
et en rappelant sur le bouton on repasse
sur le chef d'accusation la version et
master de monkey island c'est vrai mais
moncayo enlevé mais c'était quand même
beaucoup plus simple je sais je sur un
jeu de cette trempe
mais c'est vrai que
ce serait beau escabeaux alors je me
souviens c'est qu'il nous demande si il
ya nouveaux ajouts aussi oui même de
petits détails ont été faits est-ce que
ça il faut la thur alors oui apparemment
du coup ils ont ajouté il va tout a été
refait les dialogues ont été refaits
enregistré je crois que aussi les
musiques ont été réenregistrés ils ont
rajouté
d'après communiqué qu on a
malheureusement on découvre le jeu avec
vous ce soir peut pas vous affirmer tout
ça mais d'après communiqué qu'on a eu en
quoi le fait qu'effectivement ils ont
rajouté du contenu additionnel décès non
plus des ciné max ou plus et c'est donc
à priori oui en fait il que je ne
continue qu'à l'époque signalé en fait
ce qu'ils savent c'est une version un
peu étendu en turquie ça genre c'était
une directeur scott
même si je doute que équipe en faute de
l'époque de chica chic et travailler sur
le jeu donc ça c'est en gare 13
le développeur du jeu qui je fait
c'était cette nouvelle version
et c'est les développeurs de massia 3
mafia 3 le mal aimé je veux avec ses
deux ancêtres qui ont mal fait trois
malheureusement il a été
en sortie dans des conditions très
difficiles avec énormément je rendais
d'expérience bien moins bonne et moi
même alors voir jouer un match à trois
essayer de le faire ou de mal parce que
je veux être erronés dans c'est pas
l'ambiance est pour moi la source n'a
pas prise pour moi nouvelle orléans j'ai
pas de bêtises tout à fait avec mais je
suis assez rebondit sur vos commentaires
vénerie peur vous trouvez le doublage
français juste monumentales comme dans
tout les mafias ça c'est vrai que sais
tu ce qu'il faut dire que les
cinématiques et les scènes de dialogues
doublés
on se souvient de siagne qui reprennent
les affranchis dans mafia 2 3 1 doublé
avec des personnages hauts en couleur là
c'est pareil en à des personnages et
donc le doublage français bien fait on
peut s'attendre à ce que le doublage
américain sur la dotant de plus belle we
knew bordeaux dans mafia trois bennes
reaper qui est venu voir le roi je pense
de la trilogie mafia vous nous dites
vous jouez à shadow à ce que je vois la
version boost comment j'utilise comme je
l utilise aussi les graphismes sont à
quelle config vous tournez à combien de
fps environs de la rocqué à 30 fps
alors c'est vrai parler un peu technique
alors voilà un peu technique alors c'est
vrai que ce serait effectivement le f
nous vous regardez tasse est à 25 me
c'est pas bien juste mais c'est
traditionnellement au café y vivent est
à 25 images l on est plutôt sur et
j'aurais pu vous le mettre à 50 images
seconde j'en suis désolé mais je dois
jouer à sécurité puisque je t'ai pas
vraiment ce qu'est ce qu'on fait là
risation tournure
donc j'avais pas envie de tenter le
diable
mais sinon non joués a fait actuellement
doit être du 60 images/seconde constants
et effectivement on ne joue pas sur
console en jeu vous sur sur shadow
shadow en fait c'est un ordinateur en
fait ce sera un ordinateur vous louez en
fait dans le cloud et puisque je suis
plus tout quinzaine d'euros par mois va
pas faire la poésie tchado mais du coup
ils nous aident en fait bon jouer à ce
jeu puisque du coup là on a tout mis en
uvre a en fait tous les graphismes ont
eu trace sauf la synchro verticale et ce
qui nous permet de jouer en fait avec un
framerate et c'est assez élevé donc du
coup et on avait vraiment le jeu a l'air
déjà dans la version tout cas si vous
avez un shadow équivalent d'un shadow
boost donc c'est la première est bien du
coup pouvait jouer en très bonne très
bonne qualité à la mafia remastered
après j'imagine que je vais être encore
un peu mieux optimiser sa sortie le mois
prochain mais mais voilà en tout cas et
je pense qu'ils se rassurent du 36
matches j'espère en tout cas se
rassurent du 30 images secondes sur
playstation donc là vous êtes bien sûr
la version boost 90 man river ouais on
est vraiment on est vraiment sur la
version booth toute façon je suis chaud
doux il n'y a plus que ça c'est plus
possible on a essayé d'avoir d'autres
shadow château n'arrive plus à livrer en
fait d'autres d'autres éditions de
château gontier plus que boost qu'ils
arrivent à honorer au niveau des
commandes un peu triste je vous salut
merci d'être avec nous sur youtube
alex a shower chf
mon salut bonjour juan juan qui nous
distiller le jeu graphiquement vraiment
très beau pour guy guy sur youtube
également va merci à vous d'être avec
nous n'hésitez pas à commenter à réagir
si vous avez des questions et prendre
explose irbin merci de vos questions
vénerie peur qui relie vous allez
pouvoir profiter de ce chef-d'oeuvre en
ultra bas c'est vrai que 18 ans après
moi je devais y jouer je pense en 2004
ou en 2006 ça va être une expérience
très très nostalgique et je pense ça me
donnera même envie d'essayer de
retrouver le premier que j'ai en version
dématérialisée toujours dans mon petit
j'ai même hésité à la portée mais je
trouvais que ça faisait un peu trop fan
zone mais bon allez
voilà on verra ce que ça donne alors
juan juan vous nous dites la map est
bien grande
alors si l'on respecté la marque
d'origine c'est une marque qui m'ont pas
si grande que ça quand on a l'habitude
des derniers gta ou des derniers jeux
comme je sais faire the witcher là c'est
surtout une ville mais par contre très
détaillée ça il faut le dire avec
quelques petits espaces et petit domaine
en campagne les eaux mais non campagne
qui sont un peu moins intéressant parce
que finalement on se cantonne à des
scènes à saillé ad voilà là tu peux
t'amuser un petit peu là ah ouais
j'avoue clés de voiture voilà donc des
scènes en campagne qui sont un peu moins
intéressant sur lesquels vous pouvez
vous balader dans le mode open world
c'est donc pas non plus un design pas
non plus le pas non plus avec la
configuration la plus optimale pour le
ce genre de jeu disons que c'est plutôt
une mise en valeur sensation de
l'olympique plutôt que d'en sortir
les sensations sont bonnes à la batte de
base-ball moi j'aime bien ce gameplay
par contre c'est c'est une combinaison
de touches qu'on ne puisse jamais pour
dans des jeux dans des
des jeux de la troisième personne donc
je suis un peu étonné de qu'ils aient
pris de paris fin le risque de changer
complètement la façon de jouer des
joueurs mais est-ce que vous pourriez
mettre le genre plein écran pour alex
babs s'il vous plaît et 7 dès qu'ils
nous demandent quelle est la date de
sortie du jeu et à la date de sortie du
jeu
c'est le 25 septembre prochain vous avez
donc un bon mois à attendre
n'hésitez pas voilà en tout cas à nous
dire ce que vous en pensez si vous êtes
convaincus par ces images et par ce jeu
officiel inverse
vous êtes un peu déçu du corps est ce
qu'on a pu lire dans les prizioù nos
confrères c'est que le jeu garder
certaines certains vieux enfin certaines
vieilles façades de gameplay
donc ça c'est intéressant puisque c'est
vrai que le gameplay était un peu
vieillissant dès le début il y avait des
choses qui n est pas forcément très
efficace qui était plus officielle d'un
an j'étais allé quérir on va donc voir
ce que ça donne mais par exemple pour
payer le fait que le personnage qui nous
accompagnent puis sortir et tirer un peu
de cette façon ciblée sur les voitures
ça y était déjà avant et c'était je
trouve un peu plus effectif et que un
gta 3 ans gta vice city clé dans
certaines directions et olives et là il
y avait un temps tous plus de précisions
dans la gestion des sociaux libéraux
sont ajoutés c'est vrai qu'à l'époque je
crois pas mal de comparaison entre vice
city mafia 1
parce que du coup il sortit à peu près
en même temps c'est un succès 1
non non non non non effectivement gta
vice city est bien plus cartonné mais là
c'est les flics ils veulent vous arrêter
parce que vous avez passé la vitesse ou
parce que vous avez tiré alors
maintenant vous n'avez plus le choix
faut vous en faire ce que vous êtes à
deux étoiles et il ya une petite c'est
comme dans gta parce que deux étoiles
après jamais tu arriveras tomba c'est
sûr qu'on en fait qui disent que là si
vous arrêtez ils vont vous arrêter vous
allez vous faire avoir mais comme on
disait tout à l'heure si vous n'avez
qu'une seule étoile
ça c'est pour dépassement de la vitesse
autorisée on peut placer juste la prune
mais ça vous fait faire beaucoup de bien
car vous êtes sur des missions chrono
c'est un peu embêtant
il n'y a pas d'effets crypte où un peu
comme dans jeu le parrain juste ma silva
parfois
c'est pas une amende qu'on règle c'est
tout
mais il ya des scènes aussi avec des
pics rubrique où siègent monsieur un
bien j'ai vraiment beaucoup de souvenirs
de jeux mais aussi en a qui m'ont
beaucoup
échappé parce que du coup je me souviens
dans le parrain on pouvait aller voir un
commissaire de police et lui dire il ya
de l'argent qui est tombé de ma poche
serait peut-être bien finalement c'est
que tu m'oublies pendant une petite
semaine
et du coup ça permettait de faire ses
petites affaires et puis qu'ils aillent
embêté en fait les américains je connais
pas d'autres jeux qui vous [ __ ] des
amendes en direct
c'est tres merci fin c'est très rigolo
donc vous avez le contractuel qui dit
bonjour monsieur vous avez vu à quelle
heure à caraquet à quelle vitesse vous
rouliez aller au café le canal 17 b moi
j'achète direct quand il sort je kiffe
mais vous avez raison je vous dis pas ça
parce que keanu aussi jeu mais parce que
c'est vraiment à mes jeux préférés
connexes il est mauvais je vais presque
réception pendant on est assez convaincu
que vous en pensez cette façon nous on
avait prévu je sais pas si on sera un
crime sur mafia puisque vous avez prévu
de vous le faire sur la sortie tu payes
et du coup sa boîte de 1,7 avec frêche
en fait du coup était suffisamment
gentil pour nous donner en fait une
version en allant faire ce soir
mais du coup je pense que le cloud et
ont peut-être conduire jura les raisons
la centrale qui fait rejeter un long
stream sur mac l'armée aussi bien c'est
ça qu'on voulait faire déjà au sénat
si vous êtes motivés dites le nous dans
le chat et on découvrira de son de façon
un peu plus précise et est longue le jeu
avec vous et si jamais il s'avère que ce
test petite preview nous convainquent
mais je crois qu'on est pas loin d'avoir
fini d'ailleurs à des mots puisque du
coup là on va je crois que là sa
troisième en quatre éditions être la
troisième mission voilà donc du coup il
reste plus que deux missions et on a
fait une tour en fait de démo que nous a
envoyé tout key donc ça que l'animation
est pas mal ce qui manque en fait dans
ces jeux là j'ai trouv c'est des petites
interactions en plus en fait servir un
plat et un bière je viens pour jouer au
billard avec les mecs soient il ya comme
dans un gta univers dans the witcher
alors ça non c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose de en fait le jeu vous
offre certaines libertés entraîné avec
un réalisme qui est assez proche c'est à
dire vous lisez là cette possibilité de
faire le plein les amendes les vitesses
limitées avec un scénario très définis
par contre il faut pas s'attendre à jeu
e surtout il ya plein de mini jeux dans
où il ya un ultra réaliste dans tout ce
qu'on peut faire c'est vrai que c'est la
qualité des gta où on est souvent
surpris quand le fait qu'on puisse aller
jeux billard camp et dans les
distributeurs
enfin voila on n'est pas dans un
photoréalisme et céline through ouais
voilà on est on est plutôt dans un jeu
qui vous fait vivre une histoire de
façon il démarche de façon scénarisé
pourtant ils vous donnent pas
l'impression d'être dans un couloir sûr
que c'est une info de certains jeux il
vous donne quand même l'impression
d'avoir un sens de liberté et ça c'était
la force en 2002 du jeu et je pense
qu'ils ont gardé cela karine il nous dit
il que vingt-et-une personnes à vous
apparaissez direct sur youtube
on va écouter tout le monde n'a pas
aussi mauvais move ou karine je vous
invite à rester avec nous pour voir la
suite de ce test crime sans ses
productions kendrick s'est sorti en 2002
ouais c'est ça 2002 la sortie là c'est
un remake remastered assez une
définitive ovation c'est plus qu'une
série masters tout simplement est bien
dit on dirait vraiment un mélange de gta
et de mafias j'adore cette baie vous
êtes vellard convaincu en tout cas par
ce jeu merci à vous en tout cas bigot
nous donner vos avis et voilà pour
répéter
et répondre de nouveau à votre question
de tout à l'heure eh bien le jeu sort le
25 septembre
ollier cette année on verra si les
ventes sont impactés par la crise
sanitaire
par exemple dans le cinéma mais bon dans
le monde une des maths et surtout avec
et bien déconfinement que l'on connaît
je m'inquiète pas trop pour le jeu si
jamais un public est au rendez vous je
pense pas non plus en plus cela on va
sûrement se re confiner le match en 20
occasions on joue à des jeux vidéo
ah oui pour cette raison et ce serait
bonne occasion aussi pour l'acheter en
démat si vous l'achetez en démat toute
façon il va sortir on est en version
physique vous pouvez déjà pré commander
la version physique dans papa de
s'alourdir des marques sur internet
oui propos vous pouvez précommander du
courrier frontenac amazon tout ça ou
alors vraiment chez convenir dans le
magasin spécialisé qui est clair donc
voila et ce sera toujours ça furent
moins cher mais voilà le jeu va sortir
une version physique qui vous aurait du
coup les trois jeux à faire là ça va me
prendre un temps dingue
pour finir les trois jeux sachant que du
coup dans la trilogie mafia qui vous est
vendu vous avez donc ce mafia là alors
je sais il n'y a pas de décès ya rien ce
qu'à l'époque en 2006 faisait pas trop
ce n'est pas la coutume il ya mafia 2
avec tous les essais alors j'ai essayé
de leur faire avec tous les dlc avec
notamment wayne oscars aux césars ça
c'était jimmy'z revenge il y avait des
mises revenge jimmy ce but ou ailleurs
et il y avait encore un nettoyeur en
nettoyeurs et si vous l'avez fait ses
valises et les faits les extensions et
c'était chez air fait justement pour ce
soir c'est nul franchement les décès
c'est nul c'est à dire qu on sent en
chant qu'il ya eu une espèce il ya eu un
début de bonne volonté et ils ont pas
réussi en fait dans les cms et à
l'époque je pourrais pas du tout c'est
ça en avoir avec la trilogie que leurs
semblables pour mon idée c'est avec mais
à l'époque effectivement croyons utile
de laisser je sens que il n'avait pas
les moyens d'en faire quelque chose de
concret et j'ai l'impression que
j'essaie de ce qu'à l'époque c'était gta
iv qui était sorti enfin à peu prendre
une mafia 2 et du coup ils ont essayé de
faire
gta iv sur cd c'est donc c'était of the
damned et the ballad of gay tony
qu'était deux très grandes et c'est
tellement incroyable cd et c'est qu'ils
ont vendu les décès sans le jeu
principal son gta iv et d'ailleurs on
pouvait passer de très bons moments puis
de très longs moments à l'heure sur les
c'est du caca qui était inspiré un peu
de surf à renard qui on jouait tout à
fait c'était excellent tout à fait et y
avait eu ballad of gay tony on jouait le
vigile d'un d'une boîte de nuit et on se
retrouvait avec le monde du luxe et avec
des hélicoptères dorés je m'en souviens
d'un milliardaire d'arabie saoudite
francité c'était un peu n'importe quoi
et il est excellent et surtout dire ce
qui inquiète c'est que les histoires
excuse moi tu le fais mes histoires de
ddc de gta iv se croiser c'est à dire
qu'en fait donc ce qu'on voyait du coup
une histoire gta iv croisé l'histoire de
baden gay tony qui croisait aussi
histoire de leur stand amen leur offre
du coup c'était en fait trois points du
supposé différents et d'ailleurs vous
pouvez voir en fait du coup ce qui reste
de deux des sanctions jusqu'à cannes
sound avec dans gta 5 avec trevor mais
je vais pas vous en dire que si vous
avez un résultat 5 et que vous avez joué
l extension de gta iv du coup vous savez
ce qui est art à l'epo à johnny mais il
faut dire en tout cas quelle époque
rockstar était très bon pour faire des
dlc mais il était rare à faire devant
dlc et notamment au touquet les dlc qui
faisait était très mauvais même les
fallout faisait des dlc
oui aucun test et moi qui étais pas si
bon que ça et on n'était pas dans leur
meilleure période je pense qu'on était
dans la dernière période des dlc payants
ou
vous pouvez avoir de temps en temps
d'être qualitatif mais on descendait
quand même dans le niveau des dlc je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez dans le
chat mais c'est vrai que ce n'est pas
forcément
alors c'est bien pas tout à fait vrai
puisque du coup alors moi je me souviens
pour faire un peu avocat du diable
suggestion de bethesda
je me souviens que petit fallout new
vegas a été quand même score par dieye
c'est un jeu à part annoncé un des trois
était sorti à part entière et c'était
pas du tout oui mais c'est un peu c'est
un peu comme valérie gay tony épisode
stone damian alors vous vous donnez un
millier sur le moteur de fautes 3 ce
serait plutôt oui il était sur le moteur
mais mais c'était pas une extension il
était assumée comme un jeu à part et si
vous regardez dans la dans les sorties
il n'est pas construit comme une
extension de fallout 3 mais il est
compris comme un jeu va pas donc pas que
ouais c'est mon deuxième je préférais
fait toujours bluffé olalalala polonais
mais je décède suite de mr a de bons
joueurs merci d'être avec nous sur
youtube vous nous demandez si un mode
multi sera fait non ça va péter
puisque il n'y en avait pas à l'origine
et que même dans mafia 3 je crois qu'il
n'y avait pas de mode multijoueur donc
je vais me multijoueur dans les mafieux
et alors là on va pouvoir commencer
j'espère qu'ainsi dans le square va
pouvoir tirer sur des gens oh là là et
ça c'était un des défauts dans des
mafias à mon sens pas bon et notamment
sur
mafia ii il avait gardé ses défauts qui
était un peu vieillot déjà on va voir ce
que ça donne je n'avais pas été trop
rassuré par les trailer que j'avais vu
mais on va voir tout de suite ce qui
avait réussit très bien à faire les gta
iv gta5 de l'époque comment faire
c'était de donner des eaux des zones
vraiment ciblé sur les impacts
oui voyait vraiment que si on tirait
dans le bras le texte là c'est pas
simuler en tout cas ça l'était pas dans
l'eure donc si on tirait dans le bras la
mecque faisait juste à et se relevait
donc s'ils ont tiré à la mitraillette il
a et c'était un peu un peu gênant là on
va voir ce que ça donne alors je suis
très curieux alors que dans le jeu le
parrain justement il avait vraiment mis
un accent là dessus c'était vraiment on
peut désormais un gars on peut lui tirer
dans les jambes et cetera vais le porter
et lui ouais lui faire avouer qu'ils
doivent avouer des choses et le mettre
sur le board et les rambardes voir des
barbecues ou tafer ouais vous pouvez en
faire ce qu'on voulait c'était très
rigolo il n'y a pas de mini jeux pour
projeter les voitures comme dans ma fait
d'eux non d'accord du coup ça dans mafia
2 c'est un petit peu c'est des choses
que ça marche bien enfin petit mini jeux
pour crocheter voiture parce que du coup
il des moments où on voit la
maréchaussée qui passe derrière et c'est
stressant si c'est intéressant c'est que
on est vraiment dans une rue du premier
et ça c'est intéressant du parce que
souvent on est sur de fausses nouvelles
versions
qui finalement sont tout simplement à un
nouveau jeu là c'est quand même une
chance de pouvoir jouer un classique
c'est bien vrai que de beaux graphismes
et sans souffrir des anciennes la seule
magie très curieux les mâles c'est très
important je voudrais vraiment savoir
s'il est la bande son est la même et en
version remastered bien évidemment ou si
c'est une toute nouvelle puisque la
bande son était vraiment excellente
alors il y avait des décisions qui a été
fait à part entière pour le jeu mais il
y avait aussi une bande son avec du duke
ellington avec django reinhardt c'était
c'était assez unique et on était
vraiment dedans quoi et ce n'était pas
du tout sexy on n'était pas du tout dans
une ambiance
musical qui voilà qui soit caricatural
on était dans une ambiance très réaliste
et ça c'était plutôt agréable
ouais c'est pas mal ce petit point de
repère sur
jeu pour savoir où il faut tourner quand
on est sympa on arrive bon guide encore
parce que plus on tire un peu plus par
la main joueurs regardent vers
aujourd'hui tom jeu et permettre si je
pense the witcher froid il permettait en
fait d'avoir aucune aide pour aucun
repère rien puisque nos jours débrouille
toi fais ta vie là ils vous disent où
s'est déroulée cette salle a alors entré
dans la boulangerie avant d'être enfin
pouvoir intimider des commerçants
ce que j'attends depuis très longtemps
dans un jeu de mathieu pas suffi
d'instruction des sables
ok il faut lire son sens à la gym age in
on va bien envie de faire cher la
présente lettre notifiant obligations
paiement macha mensualités de payer d'un
nom est bond voilà pas payer pas payer
la taxe quoi il va nous dire sûrement
que sa femme est malade c'est tout ça
pourquoi la fois tendre attendre qu'ils
rentrent simple script et comme comme je
sais un peu cryptée il fait quoi là il
bégaie non mais l'autre était en train
de a peut-être à at on mis le doigt sur
un premier il y avait un petit bug de
pathfinding déjà là c'est entre n était
pas très pas très joli à voir
qu'est ce qui t'a 30 cents au lieu chez
pathé train de se rouler une cigarette
on va dire ça il ya plus de filtre
bonjour avis gaëtan guira merci d'être
avec une noire et vous pour vous à l'ex
diable c'est bien fait mieux que j'étais
alors faut dire que gta il a pris un
coup de vieux vis-à-vis de mafia c'est
ça c'est paradoxal parce que j'étais est
sorti était j'étais allée coup si je me
trompe pas 5
treize ans après mafia mais là il faut
dire que cette nouvelle version vient
juste de sortir et que gta est sorti il
ya quand même cinq ans je crois que
c'est en 2015 en 2014 qui est sorti
ouais en fin de vie à toute fin de vie
de 360 et de la playstation là et là il
est sorti en toute fin de vie de la ps4
donc il a une génération d'avancé mais
c'est vrai que l'effet est plutôt réussi
alors est ce que moi j'ai pu dire en
tout cas dans les previews nos confrères
et consoeurs c'est que certaines
animations faciales était un petit peu
vieillotte que certaines animations
gestuelle aussi été un peu vieillotte on
va voir si en tout cas on a une scène de
gameplay qui peut nous permettre de nous
alors c'est vraiment pas s'il faut
prendre non mais faut prendre l'argent
fait qui est sur la table je vois bien
qu'il ya une enveloppe et j'ai appuyé
sur x mais ça marche pas alors c'était
pas gagné une enveloppe un non pardon
excusez moi c'est derrière un cd r 1
qui est célérier avec la dame qui nous
insulte qui est ensuite en italien pour
l'orge papa l'italien si si oui en
général c'est pas quelque chose agences
devraient pas italien je regagne ainsi
si un jour tu m as j'y suis allé et je
suis allé dans la ville de corleone
voilà comment ça se la pète eh ben ça
c'est vraiment génial
il ya un musée de la mafia et je vous
conseille d'y aller c'est super j'espère
que si on enlevait ce que sinon je vais
rien comprendre
elle parle même en français il ya une
française anglaise et italienne alors là
à ces aléas corleone c'est magnifique
c'est petit par jet ski et des mafieux
aquarium justement oui celle amassée en
fait si à corleone a été prise pour le
par a c'est parce que c'est là qu'est
née la mafia et que l'esprit durant
gangsters de tous les temps gêne qui
était auto auto quelque chose j'ai
essayé de vous retrouver
eh bien venez de korean était mais là
bas il s'était lui le parrain le vrai
par an jusqu'en dangereux
et ça va jazzer signé encore le sang le
pauvre type étonné rage
moi je vais me fier pour pas vous dire
de bêtises rendez-vous ce beau taurine à
toto riina type dans nos tournées comme
voyais en bas à gauche on peut passer
les trajets ça c'est une mauvaise note
alors ça c'est un vrai dire la chair
parce que beaucoup de personnes je pense
l'utilisons alors que c'est aussi bien
c'est le chemin qui fait la beauté ah
oui c'est vrai que c'est une des
nouveautés qu'il n'y avait pas dans le
jeu il ya désormais des motos on a pu
croiser une motocyclette et il y en
avait pas dans le jeu original et du
coup en fait pourquoi est-ce que c'est
pas une bonne idée de pouvoir passer les
trajets sache une façon vous pouvez
désactiver option dans les options
évidemment parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
dialogues werc mais on sait pas
tellement ça c'est surtout comprendre ce
une mauvaise idée dans le sens où vu que
la police c'est un des seuls jeux ou la
police effectivement peu impacté en fait
le gameplay l'histoire du fait que si on
roule trop vite on se prend une prune
c'est un peu dommage de pouvoir passer
tout ça en fait on perd un petit peu à
ça ça me rappelle un petit jeu pas très
réussie de rockstar games et l'oeil noir
on pouvait passer complètement fn scènes
d'action est en fait finalement il a eu
un master en verre en verre et en normal
aussi bien normal mais surtout envers ce
que ça c'est j'ai regardé les vidéos
vers c'est incroyable à quel point ça
peut être mal et sans merci on peut
faire n'importe quoi jusqu'au cole
phelps et ça devient vraiment mais
burlesque de façon incroyable une façon
d'occuper tout seul mais voilà il est
vrai que c'est un petit peu c'est se
défouler s'affaisser aussi dont s'était
pas lancé j'aime la vci
elle donnait dix noms ouais ça devait
être juste juste avant c'était juste
avant j'étais à cinq je crois est sorti
avant j'étais à 5 mais l'histoire du
hockey c'est le défi ça s'est passé à
nallet sauf que c'est à los angeles
il a filmé des rouleaux oui c'est vrai
que c'était c'était un jeu auquel je
croyais beaucoup à l'époque et comme
tout le monde je crois que je n'ai pas
dans les années 10 saint-julien tensions
nées dans les années 30 par on n entend
plus tard c'est vrai mais juste avant la
première seconde
c'est vrai mais mais mais bon c'est dur
à bulawayo des noirs et les noirs qui
est sorti en 2011
j'étais bien je suis correcte dans men a
tout à fait dénonciation de dominos bong
gomis et unique rapplique à l'école tu
vois bien c'est une question très
intéressant sur lesquelles on va pouvoir
débattre
bonjour en acronymes ici d'être avec
nous sur aussi ça une accro sur youtube
vous me demandez si les édiles et 10 les
éditions définitive si l'on a faim de
mafia c'est une excellente question
puisque bas on pourrait s'y attendre ces
mesures c'est ce que ça veut dire
c'est une excellente je pense que ce qui
va le dire ce sera la réussite ou pas de
ces versions sont a été réadaptée un
nouveau public s'avère plus que si ça
marche bien on peut s'attendre à mafia
donc si ça ne marche pas on sera basé
sur
les dernières versions profiter de la
trilogie est constante cette saison ça
je pense exactement c'est un petit peu
ce qu'on appelle une ubisoft c'est à
dire que le sort une version
remasterisée cette édition-là des
affirmativement mais j'ai souvenir de
bengo de niveau qui est en sorti en
version hd est en fait qu'ils n'avaient
d'âge des quasiment que le nom sur 360
et playstation 3 pour essayer de paille
pme et de l'argent dans les poches des
joueurs mélo de l'alsace les pour voir
l'engouement qu'avait les fun le
bénévolat vendait avant de se prononcer
de se dire est ce qu'on va faire un peu
ce qu'on va pas le faire c'est là vous
êtes sur le fameux barrage un site r&d
des points clés de la ville est alors je
dois vous dire sois là pour l'avoir fait
jeu original je veux venir me dire que
là les scènes en dehors de la ville sont
plutôt belle ça c'est très beau c'était
pas beau du tout déjà à l'époque quand
on sortait il y avait notamment
certaines missions il les avait faits
sera furieux certaines missions qui
voilà qui sort d'une saison 2 sera pas
une scène dans la ferme dans ce manoir
n'était pas très joli
le rat s'est quand même passé vous avec
les petits ajouts et qu'on n'avait pas à
l'époque et comment le voyage justifie
long parcours sa pop il ya un peu de
clipping sinon pour rebondir sur le
commentaire de ghost alors ça n'annonce
pas mafia quatre matches à quatre n'est
pas annoncée du monde pas ma
connaissance pour cayenne a regardé sur
ma fille katia s'est tassée secret en
fait sur rodez l'astuce cette trilogie
déjà ils ont annoncé quasiment dernier
moment et en fait le truc c'est que
malheureusement la communication ce
mafia loisirs et le mec définitive
édition suis un peu capoté dans le sens
où le genre d'excès retire avant se
retrouver à cause du coc vides ont dû
reporter la sortie de mafia et donc du
coup en fait les trois je devais sortir
que quasiment en même temps à quelques
mois d'écart en fait c'est j'ai
l'impression qu'ils devaient c'était de
sortir par exemple fois c'était en mai
peut-être mafia 2 en juin mafia 3 et
puis voilà vous auriez vu en juillet du
coup pour les vacances du coup mafia 1
effectivement ça fait pas une trilogie
dans l'ordre ça fait un petit peu façon
tf1 on sort les épisodes quand on veut
mais c'était un petit peu l'idée et du
coup bah c'est pas passé comme prévu
mais je pense que wes ici les ventes de
la trilogie sont tout à fait honorables
il n'y a pas exclu qu' il est peut-être
une suite
alors j'espère que s'il ya encore une
suite la mafia ce coup ci ce sera pas en
gare 13 attendant il sera vraiment uk
celle qui va écrire sont occupés
d'ailleurs j'aimerais bien savoir ce qui
ce qu'ils sont en train de faire
actuellement ce studio là parce que j'ai
même pas s'ils n'ont pas s'ils n'ont pas
vendu ou s'ils n'ont pas s'ils n'ont pas
tué le studio sait plus ce qu'il devait
faire plein de jeux et finalement ça
fait très longtemps qu'on n'a pas
entendu parler d'eux mais merci en tout
cas à gaza moraillon vous salue sur
youtube n'hésitez pas si comme le
samouraï inac météorites et j'ai avec
sauvagerie avigail temps il ira ou
encore romain mister gay juste around
you she bop
n'hésitez pas à commenter et à réagir et
le chiffre qui ne disait tout à l'heure
en gros ils ont le moteur du 3 pour
refaire le 1 et le 2 et 3 où on ne peut
pas changer
c'est vrai que le 2 et 3 n'ont pas trop
changé dans la version vous avez pu
débloquer 3 absolument pas d'accord mais
quand tout cas voilà voilà le jeu quand
même si en fait ils ont vite s'y prête
ils ont un peu changé les textures du 3
pour dire voilà pour y jouer dans quatre
cas je crois
et en ce qui concerne la il faut
souffler faufiler faut pas courir
effectivement mais du coup voilà c'est
surtout ça en me disant de s'arrêter sur
fera cela quatre cas machin que je suis
l'exemple des leaders l'ultra hd machin
je ne me lancerai pas d'essayer un
personnellement
c'est bon c'est bon personne n'a entendu
ça c'est un petit ajout qu'on n'avait
pas à l'époque il n'y avait pas de
cinématique on pouvait que se taper les
ennemis on allait faire s'évanouir
il y avait des modes pseudo
infiltrations qui ne sont que
l'infiltration s'est pas passé comme
prévu thibout qui n'étaient pas déjà
très définis bon d'accord ça voilà c'est
vrai c'est assez spécial
ça rend le jeu quand même moins linéaire
c'est que du coup il ya une scène de
combat qu'on doit réaliser pour pour
avoir le pourra voir le personnage qu'on
va mieux
c'est par exemple moins d fois que j'ai
trouvé sur le dernier ghost of two shima
qu'on a pu tester ici même avec chloé
voiture deux places julien est voué à la
réalisation comme toujours c'est que
vient le jeu est un peu linéaire dans
les infiltrations la loi du coup aux us
voilà donc on peut quand même à battre
les ennemis d'un coup donc
l'infiltration est un peu plus définis
quand même mais un peu je trouve
linéaire ça c'est de l'infiltration
c'est vrai on est vraiment sûr de la
grosses infiltrations pas son hit man
ans est issu regin scène qu'on salue qui
nous dit le figaro gaming j'y crois pas
ça chez que du figaro gaming house comme
on vous propose aujourd'hui ça existe
depuis fin 2016 année kubani beaucoup on
vous fait vivre les autres 3 les trois
petits peuvent être vécus vous fassiez
les conférences en direct on vous fait
vivre est mort des jeux quand on le peut
voilà on essaye de vous en proposer
plein de contenus donc n'hésitez pas à
nous retrouver et surtout sur ce format
de stream qu'on vous propose ce soir est
bien de comme depuis trois ans on vous
propose beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
sujets d'actualité quasiment au
quotidien que ce soit sur la page
principale du figaro sur facebook sur
twitter est maintenant sur youtube on
vous donne rendez vous n'hésitez pas
ni oui ok alors ça devient un poil plus
compliqué je ne vous cache pas puisqu'en
fait j'ai pas tout à fait suivi les
conseils d'infiltration parce que c'est
fidèle à moi même j'ai fait ce que je
vais faire mieux dans hitman salariés au
fusil à pompe et puis régler le problème
bah c'est bon alors pour ceux qui ont
joué painkiller en tout cas c'était ça
le c'était ça le but du jeu voilà aussi
vous vous êtes plutôt benckiser alors ça
aussi c'est un ajout qui a été atteinte
d'une balle dans la tête et sa règle
histoire bah oui non mais ça oui il y
avait à mai
une nouveauté qui avait pas dans le jeu
original c'est que vous pouvez vous
mettre à couvert
oui c'est bien ça c'était nouveau dans
le 2 mais il n'y avait pas dans le
premier dans le premier il fallait se
mettre à couvert de façon un petit peu
abrupte et essayer de tirer alors est ce
que ça j'aime bien me direz dans
quelques secondes
ouais la gestion du recul de l'arbre
parce que ça c'est une vraie difficulté
ouais ouais il ya un peu de recul avant
de réessayer donc sa valeur et depuis je
dois je dois m'en satisfaire c'était une
vraie valeur ajoutée dans le jeu
original c'est que par exemple on voit
dans les jeux de dans les films de mafia
ou les jeunes mafia on va prendre un
thompson 1930 je crois oui à 1013
camembert tirait partout on va tirer
partout sans aucun problème est bien là
c'était plutôt difficile parce qu'il y
avait eu un recul offre à chaque balle
c'est ça c'était très compliqué à gérer
quand on commençait à s'éloigner un
petit peu et je trouve que c'était une
vraie valeur ajoutée aussi dans le
réalisme du jeu
merci en tout cas
un accroc thévenot dit parce qu'étant
donné le flop de mafia 3 le changement
de studio la sortie des définitions
redditionnelle alors peut-être
cherche-t-il du financement pour un
éventuel futur opus et autres gens c'est
vrai que ça peut être aussi les versions
alors là on est quand même sur la grille
sous lequel il plaide un jeu qui demande
quand même de l'argent plus qu'un
remastered simple comme ils ont fait
pour le 2 et 3 donc ça a dû quand même
coûté de l'argent de refaire tout ça à
zéro et de regarder
c'est pas ce qui coûte le plus c'est
vrai nom août plus en jeu c'est vraiment
de développer à enjeu depuis depuis zéro
c'est la phase de recherche de création
l'histoire assure du game design sera là
tout était déjà fait effectivement c'est
juste la technique en fait qui
complètement refaite 2 0 c'est pas le
véhicule
ouais alors par contre c'est un auto
lock c'est à dire que moi je vise rien
du tout sûr que ces voix là il target et
puis pouf
ouais un petit peu beaucoup l'ignorent
ça a eu beaucoup de jeux sont comme ça
après pour la défense du jeu j'ai pas
forcément chercher non plus admettre
dans le mot difficulté plus dur d'accord
c'est peut-être la seule vraie si vous
les amis quand vous allez faire le jeu
vous allez pouvoir vous fait dans les
mots difficultés un peu plus compliqué
avec plus de contrainte et sans gps dans
sage et je crois me souvenir qu'on
pouvait déjà tiré à partir du véhicule à
l'ancienne alors par contre c'est ce que
tu voudras ghoul je vois mes munitions
de la gauche oui il ya les munitions en
bas à gauche la mission comme hergé à
l'infini bah c'est peut-être ça qui me
fait pas trop au niveau de l'immersion
ce prime parce que je pense que vous
êtes dans un mode difficulté trop facile
non je suis normal
mais leur baisse et une oak est normal
cette news il est alors on est leur
mafia en des prunes si on roule à plus
de 35 km du coup j'imagine en or by
c'est quand on est plus de 70 km/heure
en prendre une
moi je sais pas du tout mais non parce
que je suis pas sûr que les voitures
allaient aussi que ça
facile du coup j'ai évolué et je fumais
de temps mais j'en sais trop combien de
balles depuis twitter alors en tout cas
je vois vos messages et on vous en
remercie lindsey vonn a dit vous êtes
abonné récent pour les infos donc c'est
un passant là c'est gentil merci et me
fait plaisir merci c'est gentil mais on
vous en remercie et on vous donne
rendez-vous surtout pour tous et tous
ces formats on vous remercier de votre
abonnement
guy vous qui fait le jeu basse et
écouter ça fait plaisir pour jour on
vous donne rendez-vous dessus alors
alors je peux pas vous dire s'il y
aurait une démo ou pas du jeu du jeu qui
sera disponible en version publique
avant la sortie du jeu je peux pas vous
dire on n'a pas d'info et la ccm ce
qu'on a c'est ça cette version preview
qui a été donnée à la presse
je sais pas s'ils vont effectivement
cette version passé peut-être qu'ils
vont sortir cette version là tu viens de
ce sont des niveaux à mission et conrad
a fait les deux premiers niveaux à
mission après je sais pas quoi si j'ai
téléchargé tout vu ou pas alors là si je
dis pas de bêtise ça doit faire de 40
gigawatts croit le poids pour
télécharger pour pouvoir me présenter
c'est une démo d'accord que ça prend 40
sur le ssd
donc c'est ce qui pèse de plus en vie
damman c'est bien triste mais alors je
vois vos questions et je vous en
remercie que savoura et vous nous
demandez s'il y aura des nouveautés
niveau activités annexes et bien à ma
connaissance non non en tout cas à
l'époque il ne devait pas y avait pas de
niveaux annexes il n'y avait pas de
missions secondaires puisque comme vous
le voyez là on est dans le mode histoire
le mode histoire n'est pas interrompue
par des phases openworld dans lesquels
on peut se balader et choisir ce qu'on
va faire si on va rester dans l'histoire
ou si si on va
voilà les al'inverse directement aux
missions puisque les missions sont
interrompus par des cinématiques et
après on se retrouve directement dans
une mission avec un endroit auquel
allaient pour respecter l'histoire donc
en tout cas à l'ancienne ce n'était pas
le cas le fait qu'on n'ait pas deux
missions openworld déjà dans cette
preview ne le sous-entend pas maintenant
attendons de voir puisqu'il voit ici
n'est pas la version définitive bien
évidemment ils vont faire un constat ou
à jackson ancien la salle plus dur pour
le constat alors lui cdn morelos et le
cea c'est le toque de la famille adverse
salieri voilà c'est un peu le grand
méchant contre lequel on va devoir se
battre
et là autant vous dire que la personne
qui a été emboutie est un peu stressé
tu dis que c'est de ma faute non non pas
du tout monsieur puis à l'époque je sais
pas comment accepter alors je pense que
c'est pas comme aux rails pour faire un
constat savait pas quand on se retrouve
devant un jeune de la mafia en général
c'est un peu compliqué je pense qu'il va
régler cette affaire
non elle va réparer tout de suite non il
est venu accuser sans preuve pour le
pour les pneus et je suis sûr qu'il fait
a eu de montée et on vivait vraiment le
oui c'était
heureusement et caméras nous
ces montants un peu quand même ouais bon
il
18 heures les enfants sont couchés allez
on va dire à 19 heures l'as à donc là du
coup j'ai comme l'impression que la
cinématique que vous n'êtes voire du
coup c'était pas avec le moteur yuste
mérite national qui a déjà été fait en
taxi en fichiers vidéo et le jeu à lui
et d'arnaud retourner avec les
graphismes effectivement je pense que là
malheureusement bon on blablate parce
que voilà on est en stream et c'est vrai
que pour animer un peu le truc mais je
pense que ouais c'est un jeu qui doit
être très appréciable à faire tranquille
chez soi comme un fils
ouais c'est un film ouais c'est un film
ça sert d'être pas non plus linéaire au
point
c'est pas un ou deux altercations le
dernier jeu qui est sorti des trois big
omnium annoncé par intel qui nous
adresser le méchant pour des troubles on
est quand même moins on n'est qu'un mois
réalisme
on n'ira pas de face deux tiers à ce
point là il y aura pas trop vite à ce
point là c'est vrai alors c'est pas
réactif si vous voulez ce jeu mais avec
une très bonne qualité qu'avec la
plupart de quatre qualités
cinématographiques iranien c'est vrai
mais rld et trois pour port fini détroit
récemment parce que c'était un jeu je
voulais faire depuis longtemps
c'est vrai que j'étais quand même étonné
ce que pour moi c'est être le jeu plus
abouti chez quantic dream ouais je pense
que c'est moi je pense qu'on a des mots
c'était pendant cet être le meilleur jeu
dans le sens où il ya tellement de
possibilités
il ya tellement de flins possible et
cetera voilà j'en profite pour dire que
je n'aime pas et je feuilletais old
games qu'il faut croire que on a échoué
à leur campagne
mais bien sûr c'est un petit coup de
gueule contre jeter un oeil games s'est
jamais bien traités ils ont fait
l'histoire est très trop mais le
gameplay par contre oui vous laisse
entendre que on a échoué en fait
finalement il ya un walking c'était bien
car c'est un super aleste ils sont peut
tuer certains personnages ouais mais ça
change rien je vois si parce que du coup
c'est des personnages qui parfois
reviennent vous sauvent et à la fin j'ai
fait les deux premiers mois j'ai fait
saison une saison 2
il y avait je me suis un personnage qui
ont pu aussi on l'espère
ça change complètement la fin ça change
par mail afin par exemple de la saison
je serai leur appât et montagnes
magnifiques donc l'histoire est là et
mais c'est vrai c'est vrai que c'est un
peu une technique plus à l'ancienne c4
ont influencé par le flec là vous aurez
pas de choix dans ce mafia là en
revanche
ça a été incroyable imaginons rpg de rpg
mafia j'imagine un jeu mafia un rpg jean
façon ce sera intéressant ce serait
incroyable et jensen qui a beaucoup aimé
batman tell tale aussi ouais alors moi
j'ai fait que la première se sont pas la
saison 2 quand j'ai bien aimé parce qu
il se permettait des des écarts très
importants avec les histoires et la
mythologie original et je suis d'accord
avec nous c'est sympa que l'expérience a
notamment une lettre l interprétation
tout à fait de zéro du personnage du
joker qui s'appelle john dow et ça c'est
très intéressant était très très
impertinent de faire ça et j'ai trouvé
ça plutôt cool
ouais alors ce que j'ai cru comprendre
dans ce mafia s'cusez moi pour revenir à
ce jeu c'est qu'il ya une course de
voitures de course a vraiment donné tout
à fait alors je pense pas qu'on leur a
d'abord je peux vous dire qu'elle était
dure sept courses de voitures c'était
pas gagné alors j'étais très jeune mais
quand même c'était très difficile et par
contre j'ai vu de trois extraits et
c'est très beau là on est depuis tu
alors on est dans des véhicules qui vont
relativement il ya une vraie impression
de vitesse et oui j'ai hâte de la
réserve
il faut voir ce que ça donne bah c'est
ça on va la faire
oui parce que ah oui là je sais
exactement pourquoi parce que sur ce qui
nous a été envoyé en cause de l'émission
5 à la mission 17 way aulas a d'ailleurs
la turquie avec vous êtes des champions
bon on achète le jeu promet donc là pour
vous expliquer parce qu'on fait rien
comme les autres la cour dans mafia
plutôt que d'aller faire une course et
bah on va aller prendre la voiture de
course et on va là trafiqué pour être un
peu plus avancé être sûr de gagner
alors ça c'est une petite anecdote que
je pense que tout le monde assure
notamment surtout sur gta vice city qui
m'a marqué pour ça c'était qu'en fait il
y avait des fameuses courses de biker
qui étaient des missions facultatives
dans gta vice city
oui il fallait du coup faire une course
contre des bikers alors du coup moi
naïvement et push me disais ok bon c'est
pas facile en franchement moche y est et
jusqu'à ce que mon frère yves effet émis
mais essaye de chou rave en fait une des
rues neuve bécane ce que j'ai fait est
en fait effectivement le jeu triche dire
que ils ont des motos mais tu n'es mais
ils vont mais il nous tracer nous c'est
un truc incroyable et ça du coup
effectivement c'était c'est la seule
fois où j'ai vu un jeu qui trichaient
mais vraiment alors là c'était sans
vergogne quoi et donc du fait que
c'était pas une voiture mais on pouvait
en fait effectivement leur piquer la
moto alors que la voiture à chaque fois
forcément c'est la liberté qu'offre les
gta iv cette porte
alors là ce que vous voyez est ce que
vous pouvez essayer la moto tient pas en
pro à moto et donc ce qu'on peu ce qu'on
peut voir là dans ce
dans ce mafia c'est qu'on a le choix des
véhicules et ça c'était assez sympa on
n'avait pas le choix des véhicules au
sein d'un si je crois qu'ils étaient
étaient garés à l'arrière et que vous
pouvez les choisir comme ça avait donc
là c'est quand même beaucoup plus rapide
comment ça se passe au niveau du
pilotage
bah c'est par contre c'est pas top
on la sent soir pour tourner pour
tourner c'est rigolo
je vais voir leur charge à vous ouais
bah le front est un peu trop et un peu
trop fort un peu trop près trop peu
efficace à mon goût surtout pour une pme
toute cette époque le trou mais bon en
face à moto en général j'ai dis pas le
contraire mais c'est jusque là pour une
moto tout cédé 2 s'est achevée je suis
un peu dubitatif
ça va quand même un petit peu vite mais
c'est pas ça qui ont par contre le
tournant quand je alors c'est difficile
toujours très compliqué d'expliquer des
contrôles à la manette
avec des mots mais je vais essayer une
traque du coup les tournants de la moto
sont vraiment saisissant fait à la
manette dire que vraiment c'est pas vous
dire je cherche pas comment on commence
à se dire il ya une très bonne sensation
tourne et à chaque fois que la moto donc
chance à ses rivaux lyon ça ils ont
réussi mais pour l'accélération la
décélération un petit peu moins bon jour
yann m qui nous dit je rêve il ya des
chroniqueurs gamer jeux vidéo alors on
n'est pas chroniqueur gamer on et moi je
suis journaliste et générer à côté de
moi et réalisateur ma voiture ce
voyagiste on vous propose de l'actuelle
ils sont directs et y compris la sortie
des jeux puisque nous sommes aussi gamer
ça par contre nous le sommes et on en
profite pour vous offrir régulièrement
lorsqu'il ya des sorties de jeux vidéo
sur figaro live autre chose que de
l'actu formatio neil dur on vous
proposait se détestent propose aussi
bien des actualités vidéos de lille lui
dit la vérité c'est-à-dire qu'on avait
on avait cet essai c'est à dire sa
sortie lui avec tous les boîtiers avec
qui il ya beaucoup de joueuses
journalistes joueurs au sein du figaro
est le profit surfer sur l'envié
les hawks et contenus et c est ces tests
cissé actualité puisque c'est aussi de
l'actualité
la sortie d'un film il ya par contre des
chroniqueurs cinéma au sein des finances
bern ots voilà on serine s'employer
chroniqueur vidéoludique pour vous
offrir des tests mais ça c'est depuis
longtemps depuis j'y suis là 2016 on a
commencé sur de super smash il ya très
longtemps avec beaucoup de jeu avec une
autre rédaction aussi comment avec notre
smash bros j'ai eu c'est aussi que notre
rédaction louis avec un certain gamekult
je crois voilà on vient va pas en parler
on va pas en parler puisque maintenant
il faut pas cesser ses souvenirs
douloureux pour gamekult apparemment
suite chute mais en tout cas on tient à
remercier game cube qui n'est pas
rancunier qui insu rencontre qui accepte
ou jour devenir autant en talent à cette
scène me rappelle tant de souvenirs donc
là on récupère ce fameux véhicule qui
est beau à qui a été évoqué l'été
truqués pour être un petit peu plus
efficace et vous allez le voir c'est
intéressant une fois sur le circuit ne
sais pas si on va avoir la chance et non
fondu au noir c'est fini à ces possibles
les démos font ça aussi le reste on
trouve une cool à 3,8 de démos et vite
ah oui si on l'a effectivement aulas
alors là effectivement j'imagine que là
c'est par ma faute
sahar enroula c'est compliqué le
gameplay très compliqué alors j'imagine
qu'en 25 images par seconde chez vous
sur votre téléviseur souhaite pas aussi
agréable que nous la rédaction on est à
60 images seconde constant sur mon
retour mais je peux vous assurer que
quand vous avez joué au jeu ouais c'est
dur et ça c'était vraiment et c'est
impressionnant c'était toute la
la force de jeu et ne pardonne pas et
surtout les véhicules sont très
facilement dommageable donc il faut
faire attention il faut pas rouler trop
vite et voilà je suis pas l'avantagé
quand vous pas lâcher quand vous preniez
cette voiture
même si les flics vous poursuivez
vieillit d'être inquiet ouais donc au
niveau des chronos on s'en fout là au
niveau des prunes il pouvait pas vous
rattraper de toute façon passé voilà là
ce que vous voyez c'est pas le fait que
julien ce très mauvais en conduite c'est
tout simplement que c'est très dur à
utiliser et qu'il ya peu très passé à
chasser les morts dans des bars par la
vitesse des chasseurs ouais je triche me
met sur la piste du tramway dont
savourions petit peuple ont joué la
sensation
bon alors ça pendant qu'ils avaient pas
l'ancien parce que vu la l
la légèreté du véhicule l'épreuve car ça
c'est pas très riche comme joueur bah là
c'est un peu moi réalise qu'à l'ancienne
bonjour asie au pas et merci d'être avec
nous vous demandez si c'est le 1 ou 2
passes et le un ce1 ne rêvez pas il on
n'est pas sorti après mafia la première
édition et là on est en train de vivre
une des premières vous avez suivi gps a
gps et un gps belle époque des années 30
et bien sûr
ces gps et il le voit dans sa tête
et voilà et c'est vrai que
sasson vitesse et graphique du jeu et là
vous voyez par exemple cette sensation
de vitesse on ne l'avait pas mais je
n'avais pas l'émoi que ça c'est qu'on
doit agréable lui fournit sur deux
kilomètres pour que ça s'arrête le web
pour la france je pense que vous l'aurez
pas qu'on va perdre lamentablement
lamentable c'est compliqué c'est une
guitare
ghanem qui nous demande de parler de la
bo aussi qui comporte les plus grands
standards du jazz comme keith drake de
reinhardt et du duke ellington on peut
en parler on en a parlé deux fois déjà
mais avec grand plaisir la bo qui
beaucoup standard la rue des standards
qui sont qui sont bas voilà qui sont
très très propre à la période à l'emploi
on va faire ce truc et la voiture
n'était pas tranquille
non là je crois que c'est lui qui va le
truc est non je me souviens plus ça fait
très ambitieuse et si ouais c'est ça
voilà il a truqué que d'accord alors
line scène qui nous pose une question
qui nous demandent s'il y avait de
l'openworld dans le premier mafia alors
il y avait un aubry noir mais dans un
mode à part entière c'est-à-dire un mode
où il n'y avait pas de mission une
mission secondaire et c'est un mode
qu'on retrouve ici dans ce
dans cette version là je trouve que
c'est un pari assez osé puisque saadé
s'impliquent ce que ce soit vraiment
réellement une version bien propre à
celle de 2002 qui soit vraiment fidèle
et ce qui ne se fait plus trop parce que
maintenant on préfère on préfère faire
un mode open world simple à la gta et
maintenant ça se trouve dans tous les
jeux open world d'ailleurs je suis
toujours pour votre question asio pas et
bien sur quelle plateforme i sort ça
sort sur ps4 xbox one et pc et
probablement pourra s'y attendre de
toute façon dans un tweet ce site web le
sueur ps -cinq wii sortira sûrement sur
ps1 quai sur le problème si vous l'avez
sur ps4
vous savez on pourra y jouer si on a la
version matérialiser la la c'est
compliqué la section piqué alors oui je
crois qu'il eut des communiquer là
dessus sur les gps 406 compatible ps1
croule h hae trois minutes 26 ash ouais
parce que compliquer comprends pas
pourquoi ils vont mettre ce chronomètre
parfois pas dans le plus que les moteurs
surchauffe de housses et ça voilà
attention nous retire de l'image de
seconde ça tombe de voir la carte ah oui
tiens très bonne idée
donc ça c'est la ville de lost heaven un
petit peu pompé sur sur new york bien
évidemment avec little italy chinatown
centrale island qui me rappelle vous
verrez beaucoup manhattan voilà bonjour
eric fan zone où vous demander si ces
mafias de ou un autre c'est mafia 1 dans
un mois un peu plus la flandre défensive
édition tendre et on a la chance de
pouvoir vous faire vivre cette preview
en direct qui voit là est disponible
depuis aujourd'hui 17h donc on vous la
propose on la découvre avec vous
n'hésitez pas si vous avez les questions
des réactions
par contre depuis que le gars il a
trafiqué véhicule il ce qui tourne moins
bien je sais pas si c'est voulu mais ça
tourne plus pareil parce que du coup et
je ne trouve pas qu'il soit parce qu'il
a saboté vraiment le truc encore il a
fait un travail de cochon gars oui je
vous assure et est moins rapide chasse
en moins rapide moins poussive étouffe
assez d'accord alors nacro tv vous nous
demandez si des versions définitives de
mafia 2 est sorti plutôt spécial du
maintien alors oui on vous donnait un
peu plus de détails la mala les versions
de mafia ii et iii sont sorties en
avance nous ce ne sont pas des versions
définitives
ce sont des versions qui ont été
refaites à lille 0 1 comme sensibles non
s'ils sont des versions remastered
simplement merveilleux qu'ils appellent
quand même définitive tout est minuté
sénat trilogie qui a défini est régi
définitive mais du coup il fait 6 mafia
2 heures vous pouvez déjà rejouer mafia
2 donc du coup définitive édition et
mafia 3 définitive édition si vous les
avez achetés en dématérialisé sinon il
va falloir attendre que
les grossistes telles que auchan se
fasse livrés vous pouvez déjà essayé en
fait je la mafia de 24 heures après moi
c'est parce que je vous recommande
puisque à priori l'histoire de mafia un
prêt c'est une histoire de mafia 2 fait
des croisements dans les histoires et à
un seul parent seul je vous dirai pas
quand dans le jeu mais dément
on retrouve un personnage voilà je vous
dirai pas plus j'espère en tout cas
qu'ils ont respecté ça parce que c'était
une scène qui faisait vraiment chaud au
coeur j'avais joué à mafia 2 lors de sa
sortie je vais acheter des one puisque
basse et mafia 2 quand même
on va regarder combien de temps il était
sorti après il y avait dû sortir en 2010
ouais ouais je reçois de 2010
il était sorti en 2010 très exactement
bravo ce jeune avait pas de lien on
était avec un tout nouveau personnage
une toute nouvelle histoire mais un
moment ont croisé le personnage de mafia
un certain personnage qui voit là on le
retrouvait je vous dis pas comment pas
pourquoi si vous avez fait le 2 bat
n'ose pas il n'est pas dans notre chatte
s'il vous plaît mais en tout cas je vois
beaucoup beaucoup de réactions julien
c'est tellement bien fait que j'avais
pas remarqué que c'était bien parce que
j'ai rejoué o2 définitive édition ils
étaient déjà bien fait ouais voilà donc
pour répondre pour terminer et de
répondre à votre question à ses yeux pas
un an et pour répondre complètement
honnêtement vous pensiez que c'est
lequel le mieux le 1 ou 2 bat le 1e 2
complètement oui mais parce que julien
ici présent n'a pas fait leur un mois
j'ai fait les deux eh bien c'est la
bonne occasion pour faire le jeu vous
propose de re parler une fois qu'on aura
fait les deux enfin cher que vous aurez
fait le dos rond en débattra vrai que
j'aurais fait donc je vois là quand vous
aurez fait leur mais sincèrement le 1
était en fait déjà il était beaucoup
plus précurseurs dans ce qui se faisait
dans le jeu vidéo à cette époque il
avait un scénario qui pour moi était un
peu plus solide on était beaucoup plus à
tous attachés par les personnages y
avait des revirements d'histoire qui
était assez dingue et surtout des
espaces c'est vraiment péché
vous pouvez aller sur un aéroport dans
un grand musée on pouvait aller dans des
petits endroits un peu qu'ils aient un
blogueur on allait faire un cambriolage
dans un manoir on pouvait aller aussi
dans la campagne il se retrouvait en
pleine nuit sur lui tu as trahi par des
suivis par des mafieux et s'en sortir
comment y avait aussi un scénario qui
était beaucoup plus solide que mafia 2
mai mafia ii avait sept chances d'être
peut-être plus immersif à ce qu'il était
il est sorti rien que huit ans après
c'est pas rien et donc du coup avait une
vraie valeur là dessus et sur la bande
son qui était magnifique
il y avait une scène qui se passe dans
les années 20 des années 30 dans la
neige
magnifique aussi avant que notre
personnage débuta la seconde guerre
mondiale en sicile d'ailleurs jugé non
maintenant c'est après si on y était
mais non c'est après alors dans mafia
dossiers se fait de saturer dans l'hiver
comme et sa presse quand il revient à un
bailleur b après avoir fait justement
c'est en fait il était blessé en italie
ah oui c'est ça c'est ça
les messins isaïe et rapatrié du coup
aux etats-unis la première partie et sur
l'année comme ça c'est ça et ça c'était
vraiment super merci donc voila moi je
vous donne mon avis qui est fait des
deux et là on voit que la relation
fidèle
pour moi le d'ailleurs ces bleus alors
là je vous cache pas que ça fait très
longtemps que j'ai vu cette scène de
jolies d euros et ça fait très longtemps
que j'avais envie de tester sa course
devrait cette course dans mafia et
autant vous dire qu'il y avait pas
beaucoup de jeu qui permettait de faire
une course avec des véhicules de cette
époque est alors parti à prendre vos
commentaires alors que je viens par sur
les starting blocks qui ça y est je
m'approvisionne tentateur sportive vous
êtes en dernière position
15e position alors que julien entame son
premier virage à gauche
il continue de dépasser trois véhicules
à la suite oui c'est cela au bien jouer
julien quelle belle performance du
sprinteur français le traitement en
double et voilà pour ma petite
improvisation deux monitrices dans la
24e
voilà alors la voiture de course bleues
ça ressemble à une peugeot qu'action de
dargah matin peut alors là je ne suis
pas assez spécialiste de véhicules mais
on vous remercie en tout cas de ceux là
là je sais pas là là là yachvili cuisse
tout cela mais mais voilà faut savoir
qu'il n'ya pas de c comme dans gta il
n'y a pas de version officielle des
véhicules
ce sont des versions
avec des noms fictifs il ya mais voilà
ce sont des reconstitutions quand même
très très très très réaliste et je peux
vous dire que ben ça c'est pas compliqué
à huit ans après le jeu est beaucoup
plus beau de fantaisie pas très bien
joué et cette course c'était vraiment
très difficile il fallait absolument la
gagner elle était très très très
difficile parce que vous voyez là c'est
très compliqué de rouler et dans cette
vie dans cette voiture si vous osiez en
tonneaux vous m'auriez directement parce
que c'était beaucoup plus compliqué ne
restez pas un tonneau donc assez bon bon
vous êtes un peu tombé sur la tête là
comme un vrai mais un casque ah ouais
voilà les véhicules et bien saboté par
le mécano il a dit tout à l'heure que la
prochaine voiture que tu lui ramènerait
le trafic raid avait coûté voilà nacro
merci
liane hem vous nous dites bon après
c'est la mafia c'est bien joué en jeu
vidéo c'est marrant à voir au ciné en
séries mais dans le monde bien réel
c'est la mafia c'est pas toi tu vas en
effet et la russie suis allé faire un
petit tour en sicile n'ya pas longtemps
j'ai appris notamment la balle que 70%
des clos maire qui se paye encore des
plots devant donc la mafia ça existe
toujours mais ça a juste changé de forme
et c'est vrai qu'on est d'accord que
dans la culture c'est toujours assez
rigolo avoir mais que le en vrais
enseignants et rigolo la cosa nostra
comme on l'appelle dans nos sentiers qui
dit pas de bêtise à cosa nostra
c'est un récit italy's la mafia savez la
fia américano italienne non non non je
crois que servir la mafia sicilienne
dites nous dans le chat si je ne me
trompe pas
résultat si je me trompe je pensais que
c'était ma fille américaine rite aid
justement werber émigré aux états unis
bref à peu rattrapés je crois qu'en fait
le moteur de la voiture un peu un peu
pris de dégâts quand j'ai fait mon vol
est myope cette hormone normal n'y avait
pas de valeur faut savoir que dans le
mafieux originale y avait je crois pas
qu'il y avait deux modes de difficulté
ce qui du coup et rendait le jeu
difficile si on était haut rhin j'étais
jeune et je peux vous dire que déjà ses
rivaux j'en ai j'en ai vraiment bavé a
passé il y avait sur et il y avait un
autre niveau d'infiltration qui était
très compliqué dans un manoir vous faire
les cambrioler un manoir de personnes
riches
c'était super dur mais c'est la même
erreur que s'il n'y avait pas ce soir
vous rassure c'était très rarement à
ghanem confirme ce que je disais nostra
sicilienne merial merci bien
[Musique]
effectivement langage je vous cache pas
que alors je sais pas s'ils ont
effectivement la voiture après les
dégâts et du coup bah maintenant est un
peu moins rapide qu'avant où ils
manquent de décence je sais pas mais en
tout cas c'est bien sûr en tout cas du
coup l'appétit manche m'a fait
complètement distancé par tout le monde
allez je reprends ma carrière de
commentateur sportif alors qu'on
approche à la fin du deuxième tour
la 10ème tour vous êtes vous désormais
en quatrième position alors que les 5e
talonne
n'hésitez pas à aller un peu plus vite
julien mais sans leur entrée dans si
vous allez prendre encore plus de dégâts
pendant tout ce mois je suis moi j'étais
un peu mario kart china moses
bah oui ça marche bien quatre mini mario
kart ça marche bien je faisais ça sur le
gran turismo ne marche pas très bien
c'est avec la société serait qu'ils
décorent son look avec une ambiance très
peu connu soyons honnêtes et donc ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on a rarement
dans le jeu en open world notamment avec
des véhicules
c'est qu'on peut du coup suivre sa
vitesse son temps en temps réel et ça
c'est vraiment top
vous voyez en bas à droite pour voir la
finale
ce dos de cheval comme je vous disais
allez faire le plein si lointaine où on
verra dans le monde open world sortira
le 25 septembre
y'a pas de la nitro
tout cas c'est un peu après mais vous
pouvez suivre la vitesse en temps réel
et ça c'est plutôt agréable
ça change un peu et ça rentre encore un
peu plus merci parce que c'est mort donc
la vraie m celui ci soutient
grande de l'intérieur va bien passé
campagne automne
dites-nous si en tout cas vous avez des
références des oeuvres culturelles qui
vous ont qui vous ont pas envoyé les
sopranos à bages en profiter c'est du
coup a pas d'accord il y aquelques une
erreur franchement stupide je me
projette pour confesser j'ai commencé
les sopranos depuis moult années c'est
vrai il est dur à finir il est très très
bon et du coup j'en suis la dernière
saison mais j'ai jamais perdre et je
pense que c'est vous voyez qui le je ne
fais pas de pitié si vous leur faites
vite fait si on n'arrive pas tant pis on
va se quitter là dessus je pensais je
pense que ça vous aurait pu voir à peu
près ce que ça donne je suis content que
vous avez pu voir le mode course parce
que c'était un niveau un peu
emblématique de mafia qu'il était encore
déjà à l'époque difficile et là vous
voyez que julien est en mode normal
qu'il n'a pas réussi alors c'est pas un
jeu qui est donné comme ça à nez avec
lequel on va on va s'en sortir
directement
moi je suis curieux de voir les autres
niveaux je me suis un certain niveau qui
ont un peu traumatisés qu'ils étaient
très difficiles
on verra ça le 25 septembre
vous répondrez merci yann qui a répondu
à kevin rigaux on salue sur youtube
demandait ce que c'est qu'un jour ces
mafias
définitive des chats le ring master et
bien d'un jeu sorti en 2002 et qui est
bien refait totalement le jeu un jeu qui
avait très mal gino mais qui du coup se
retrouvent et bien avec des graphismes
et maniabilité
quand je vais voir ce jour on va dire
tiens il ya name qui me dit vous avez
beau frère intégral dvd de brooklyn et
le bailleur jeu c'est vrai je l ai pas
vu non plus là on change de ton change
de monde là on est plutôt à l'époque de
la prohibition si j'en ai la 12 e tron
pyatt
atlantic city c'est ça je crois que
c'est ça tu as vu non plus mais ça c'est
une série bio non non non rien ne perce
pas y avait aucune burkina bailleur
c'est une série qui est sorti dans les
années 2010 ouais parce qu'on a vécu
cet acteur et d'aussi par exemple
tout le temps son nom aussi comme robert
duvall
vous étiez avec nous en début de cela m
g la chauffeur du helmand
pour me souvenir de son nom de
personnage d'emplois non je crois que
tout est effectivement j'ai bien cassé
mon moteur et que c'était les carottes
étaient déjà cuites la surpression sa
gérante au plus vite comme ouais mais
c'est un peu un peu ça vous de ne pas le
dire que les sodas perd de vue de
pallier en fait
la musique est à st pas franchement
l'ambiance elle s'empare du coup la
musique on a dû abaisser évidemment pour
offrir un mix non mais vraiment j'aurais
que ceux agissant sans m'avancer sans
m'avancer avec trop de risques que les
excellentes la bo de l'original était
déjà bonne et ça m'étonnerait qu'ils
aient fait voir bien
puisqu'il n'y avait qu'à reprendre déjà
système
et voilà c'est bien ce que nous dit ian
king zig sebrango l'intérieur est bien
la série qui se passe au milieu des
gangsters italo-américain le jeu la
prohibition jeu attenti city la deuxième
ville du jeu après las vegas oublie pas
alex beh web qui nous dit les voitures
vont trop vite c'est pas normal alors
c'est vrai qu'elles vont un peu plus
vite que aimerait enfin je pense je suis
pas un spécialiste du véhicule de cette
époque mais ça allait un peu moins vite
dans le jeu original et c'était déjà
difficile donc là vous pouvez voir que
j'essaye de me souvenir un petit peu de
mes années ford sur xbox à repenser à
beaucoup plus simulation klaxons ça je
trouve klaxons ah oui on peut
fractionner youtube ouais et
klaxonnaient d'ailleurs je tiens à dire
se rassurent file des véhicules de
klaxons est toujours assez incroyable
faut l'éviter
ouais ouais faut éviter de tremplin
j'aimerais bien quand même vous montrer
la fin de la démo kosten ça qu'on allait
droit d'ailleurs tu payes nous a dit
qu'on un centime en droit de prétendre à
être jeu en main ce crime j'aimais
beaucoup quand même
on est en décadence qui agréable et ce
qui est très sympa c'est qu'il ya eu
autant de je trouve qu'ils ont été assez
généreux
avec le nombre de niveaux qu'on peut
faire ouais pour vous non pour vous
donner une idée pour un jeu qui sort
dans un mois quand même je vais terminer
de façon je suis assez grand parce que
j'ai vu
j'ai vu certains niveaux que j'avais
envie de voir ça fait plus pressant je
pense que je développement est
évidemment terminée qu'il part
l'impression aux petits oignons pression
mais a du coup j'essaye j'essaie de
m'appliquer pour qu'on voit là on voit
la fin de la démo du coup il ya ces
plans comme ça c'est nouveau il y avait
pas dans les anciens y avait dans le 2
mai il y avait pas dans l'eure ça me
rappelle the saboteur
ah oui pourquoi pas du tout non non ça
pas du tout pas du tout oui on voit des
montagnes aux loges de la ville de paris
c'est montmartre ces buttes chaumont
non alors oui voilà tu étais au
graphique et les approximations c'est en
fait pas un mauvais jeu non non je suis
pas d'accord car déjà bon moi je
trouverais toutes les excuses du monde
the saboteur moi c'est un coup de coeur
the saboteur
c'est vrai brian large et respectueux
respect mais the saboteur en fait faut
savoir que l'équipe de développement
s'étaient plaints des milk studios à
l'époque c'est le créateur de star wars
battlefront 1 et 2 2 et pop en anglais
et en fait ils n'ont pas du tout le
temps fait de finir de saboteurs qui en
fait toute l'équipe était déjà viré
avec une telle histoire
et donc pas eu le temps de finir ils ont
les saboteurs qui est un jeu à auzat
moteur diesel est aussi à la base
plus anciens je pense à batz-sur-mer
voilà un coup mike et moi mais je sais
que ray the saboteur ce qu'un très bon
jeu j'ai beaucoup aimé à la diacre
artistique de saboteurs saboteurs
bien faire
bon on n'y arrivera pas on va pas vous
allez devoir travailler un peu sur ce
niveau ce ne sera pas pour ce coup là
non je pense que malheureusement pour va
pas vous montrer la fin du de mafia on
est les piteuses performances dans notre
ami julien qu'une aile qui se retrouvent
délégué à la 3e place la coupe ne sera
pas pour ce coup-ci
mais on vous en remercie en tout cas
nous avoir fait découvrir ce jeu et bien
je pense qu on va se quitter comme vous
nous dites
yann est mono dit vous n'allez pas voir
le temps passer sur ce jeu c'est le
genre de jeu quand on a 8 ans on meurt
vive horloge complètement et bien nous
aussi on a un peu oublié landes
bien qu est ce qui t puisque c'était un
plaisir de faire ce test sur un jeu
qu'elle avait vraiment hâte de découvrir
les également bien pour vous retrouver
sur du jeu ah bah tiens oui elianem qui
a tout à fait vous parliez de pandemic
studios julien c'est pas un grand nom de
société avec les temps qui courent c'est
pas faux mais ils sont morts donc en
tête pour ça que the saboteur est un
mauvais jeu allez on va se quitter sur
six
non mais en tout cas je
merci à tous d'avoir été
à réagir avec beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de commentaires intéressants
oui merci à tous vous en remercie
c'était passionnant pouvoir parler de
jeu de mafia 2 films de mafia 2 séries
de maintien voilà donc on a joué à mafia
définitive edition un jeu qui sera
disponible le 25 septembre
n'hésitez pas à nous dire ce que vous en
pensez en en replay dans les
commentaires on ira consulter ça et moi
je m'intéresse aux branches quelques
jours moi je propose que pour ceux qui t
il montrant fate le trailer de mafia un
de très bonnes idées très bonne idée ça
fera chaud au coeur et bonjour et n
hello and home l'âme qui nous dit j'aime
bien du vietnam carton plein avec green
day my view elianem qui vous souhaite
bon courage pour la course alors que
julien va faire revivre et bien vous
allez pouvoir voir de vos yeux
la différence entre mafia et mafia 1
définitive edition 18 ans de jeux vidéo
dans la tronche
c'est ce qu'on va se prendre dans
quelques secondes dito d'ailleurs si
vous y avez joué je sais qu'on avait un
internaute août alors qu'il connaissait
très bien le jeu qui avait l'air d'être
aussi fun que moi et voilà le trailer de
mafia 1 que vous pouvez voir du coup
voilà et leur dire qu'il ya plus que
c'est qu'on lui aussi coup de vieux
surtout quand on
de se quitter sur ces images voilà donc
voyez effectivement ça c'était vrai
graphisme du coup de 2002 vous voyez
complètement là la différence qui a été
très bon et il est il n'avait pas à
rougir face à des égyptiens de trouver
même un peu plus joli qu'un gta 3 défis
avec
l'esthétique est reproché là vous voyez
c'est la mission qu'on a fait en tout
début soleil avec la construite entre
eux le taxi et ça c'est ce qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure avec tom le devoir et
loki qui se fait prendre en est bien en
choque par un autre véhicule derrière
lui et tommy angelo le personnage
principal qui incarne et qui vous le
voyez bas bien vieilli désormais
puisqu'il est refait à neuf jeunes
salieri donc le chef pour lequel on
travaille ça c'est vrai que le coup là
en mettant du coup là pour avoir joué au
jeu a pendant une heure et demie on n'a
qu'une heure et demie sur mafia
effectivement revoir et graphisme de la
fia on voit vraiment la différence y
avait déjà des bugs starbucks et qu'il a
son arme sur eux et du queens
parce qu'au début il n'est pas c'est pas
un mafioso qui sait faire il n'a jamais
utilisé d'armes
il était juste un petit taxi et il
apprend il apprend à ça c'est rigolo
le conte siguiri franck ici je me suis
bien et il aime qui nous dit à l'époque
il était bien mafia 1 c'était un jeu
purement adultes par contre pour les
gamins s'était pas recommandé tout à
fait et la course convient de faire bien
vieilli elle aussi désolé j'ai pas
trouvé la bande annonce que c'est pas
trop grave c'est déjà beau de pouvoir
voir ce ses petits ces petits signes
avant n'hésitez pas en tout cas si ce
gameplay ne vous a pas convaincu y ait
quand même aller jouer à mafia si vous
êtes
si vous êtes motivés parce qu'il y avait
vraiment de belles choses de belles
histoires avec vote avant histoire
d'amour qui se passait au ladhof
j'en parle au même moment c'est
magnifique histoire d'amour des
histoires de trahison des histoires de
gangsters
c'était très beau j'en parle avec le
coeur et avec de très bons souvenirs
trahison créer ce cas on vous salue si
vous nous quittez alex babs on vous
remercie d'avoir été avec nous pour la
fin de ce live
merci à tous et donne salieri vous salue
également comme tommy angelo nos
personnages fétiches
ah oui et belinelli niveau dans une
église qui était super aussi
et voilà pour ce trailer de mafia 1 un
jeu sorti le 25 août 2002 dix huit ans
plus tard nous sommes il est corrompu le
padre oui tout à fait oh
lalalalalalalalala mais je suis né voilà
en tout cas pour pour ce test de mafia
définitive edition jour merci de l'avoir
suivi avec nous je vous remercie julien
qu'une aile
merci thibault d'avoir réalisé et
d'avoir joué en même temps pour une
belle prouesse de pas facile technique
mais vous avez besoin d'être sorti comme
un chef comme d'habitude ghanem qui a
une histoire d'amour même du sexe où il
y avait une petite scène chaude à
l'effet que c'est vrai mais qui était
beaucoup moins choquant que dans les
versions hacker de gta san andreas
voilà bien sûr mais c'était chaud sa
relation avec sa petite amie ouais mais
c'était une belle histoire d'amour voilà
en tout cas merci yens m merci allez
merci à tous merci nomme l'âme kevin
ribot merci à tous d'avoir été avec nous
on vous donne rendez vous très vite pour
de nouveaux contenus vidéo ludique bien
évidemment mais aussi pour de l'actu au
quotidien sur la page principale du
figaro sur youtube sur facebook parfois
mais également et bien sûr sur twitch
merci julien je vous souhaite une bonne
soirée très bonne soirée à tous et à
très bientôt sur je me rendrai à tout ce
chahut
[Musique]
cinquième temps
pourquoi la méthode pour
moi ce que vous êtes
ce pays
[Musique]
c'est sur ce thème à naxos
ap
[Musique]
en haut lieu on ne sai année
nous entendons
[Musique]
parce qu'ils avaient capitaux des
catholiques ogec prix ultra carnac frigo
[Musique]
époque des méta analyse ministre
il
préformation favre en amazone
instruments